welcome to the last word episode number
129.
it's another glorious friday we're back
in front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord whose unique
content is truly a refreshing addition
to the destiny community
with top tier pvp analysis and
insightful coaching in the fps space
all done with an iconic half glove and
the most soothing tools you'll ever hear
on street
introducing the created host of the
ascended nomad youtube and twitch
channels
the lord of self-improvement and
constructive criticism
and the proud hunter who is never afraid
to throw some sarcastic shade your way
live from toronto canada and making his
debut
at the campfire of the last word
my man lord ascended no man how you
doing sir
i'm doing very well that was a hell of
an introduction i'm sorry
iconic half glove are you serious this
is iconic
it's iconic but you got like this
michael jackson dig going
but like you're doing culinary stuff
like it's very hot
yeah it's literally this is literally
just to prevent like
uh like it's for part rejection for my
time it's a
drawing glove but that is iconic and i
feel
now indebted to the art community for
having used this for
i don't know a decade now now suddenly
i've claimed it as my own
according to uh cognito but anyways
thank you for the intro and i'm glad to
be here thank you for having me
absolute pleasure man long overdue and
uh like i said he
put me on to your content and the first
thing i came out i was like
pvp crucible i can talk freely now
i'm not with hell no it's so funny
because we trade back on
intros and i was like he's yours by the
way and he's like why and i was just
like you'll know
like first word crucible done i was like
yes
someone speaks my language man but uh
how you been otherwise man
uh it's been it's been good it's been an
interesting uh beyond like
expansion um especially for us pvp mains
we
were really we're really hanging on here
um i mean
there's there's a lot of goods there's a
lot of goods that's that's
been done under the skin for pvp um
and i think a lot of people have been
have noticed and they've been talking
about it with respect to the matter
but yeah it's a bit thin on the ground
as an expansion i love beyond light
i think the storytelling the core story
could have been better but
all the extended stuff the lore the lost
sector storyline with the darkness
fragments from
uh with uh elsie bray all of that was
top notch stuff i've really loved the
pve grind in this game now with the
master lost sectors empire hunts
um the more deterministic rewards out
there
hawkmoon being an actual skilled weapon
to use
adored even was was was a pleasantly
even
even though it's very short it was a
pleasant grind um
as a player experience i think the
online is is starting to move destiny
in the right way it's it's finally
continued on the momentum that forsaken
brought in
in terms of the course correction and
it's just taken to it to its natural
progression after what happened with
shadow keep
um yeah i'm good
i was like and we're out i don't know if
we can follow that that
amazing introduction to beyond light so
um honestly like we do want to talk
about destiny beyond light and all the
things that happened but we want to get
to know you a little bit first and
first thing i wanted is where'd the name
come from
which is
that's where you begin so so i was
watching your last um
podcasters preparation you went on for
three hours and i genuinely don't think
that's long enough for me to explain the
origins of this thing
but no okay i'll do my best new record
everybody new record it's coming
so nomad is a direct reflection
of me because i have lived
okay so i was born in pakistan that's my
country of origin
um for the first four years of my life i
lived in pakistan
then i moved to america because my dad
got a job with my brother working for
not my brother my uncle his brother um
they've been working in san francisco
together on a new venture
um they sold that and then moved to
england my dad got a job in banking and
moved to england
uh brought the family with with that
with him um and then
england was a wild time it was only like
a year and a bit and then
he got a job in dubai um
so this is before dubai is the dubai you
know of it right now this is in 1999.
and um yeah so we moved to dubai and i
stayed and lived there in dubai for
about that's where i grew up for
basically 10 years is in dubai and
through there like my my upbringing was
very very
varied it was very british it was a
british school uh
most my classmates and teachers were
british um but there were people from
all walks of life there
a lot traveling as i was young lots of
field trips to like oman kuwait uh
the middle east uh one time to to
mauritius
this is a lot of traveling it was a very
internationally international school and
an international experience
and then i decided to do college here in
canada
um and i've been here for the last 10
years and
i'm canadian now but basically the the
the term nomad comes from the fact that
yeah you wonder i wander around
everywhere and
and it's been such a defining aspect of
my life that probably isn't going
anywhere anytime soon
because even now i've been in canada for
a while and i and i and i love this
country and i owe
a great debt to this country but there's
there's a part of me that's looking for
the next next adventure
so and obviously with the pandemic
that's not possible but
yeah um yeah so that that's where the
name comes from the ascendant part of it
is just
related to self-improvement and and
wanting to become better and it's also a
play on
ascendence i thought you had ascended so
you were just better than the rest of us
so
i mean
he didn't dismiss that maybe
he caught there right i hadn't embraced
that yet but sure i'm i'm just saying
i'm just saying my tree is really pretty
and i know it's better than everybody
else that's all he says
yeah all i'm saying is i was made in the
lab
nice absolutely this is cool this is
cool nice little backstory oh the other
day that was cool
i was gonna ask you too and just like
just looking over your gaming history
and um
one thing that caught my eye was just
like you being forged
kind of initially competitively in
racing games
yeah that was actually pretty cool so
tell me about that
i like that so like i told you guys
before it was it was formula 199.999
that was my first ever video game and i
think that has a lot to do with it
but growing up my dad is a huge
gearhead i guess you guys call them
gearheads petrolheads
they all count um yeah so so
growing up with with like my dad you
know being in dubai we're not exactly
worse off
right we're we do all right for
ourselves you can say it yeah you're
doing fine
you do it yeah it's cool my family my
family is doing fine i'm
sort of just hanging in there you
haven't inherited it yet but it's it's
out there they've got several decades to
go before i take up the torch all right
so um yeah so so growing up
we grew up around a lot of people who
love to flash different cars for us we
always had a new car
every like a year or so just because my
dad is really interested in cars and he
always wanted to try new things
um so so the love of cars was very
organic it was very much part of our
family
um and that extended and permeated
through every aspect of my personality
and when
multiplayer gaming started really
kicking into gear during the ps2
era and then started getting a lot more
uh widespread through xbox 360 and ps3
uh that's when i started really taking
note of of games like
uh forza and uh you know gran turismo
and i started i started participating in
local tournaments because of that
because those are the only games i
played i only played racing games
growing up wow
there was there was an issue partially
because
first-person shooters had horrible lag
in the middle east
i was playing on a 128k
dial-up connection till 2007.
wow so we upgraded to the fancy one
megabyte per second package
in 2007 and that coincided with me
uh playing halo 3 for the first time and
getting very addicted to team swat um
and so the competitive side of me that
was nurtured
and sort of incubated from uh racing
games
really took on became its own little
monster with halo 3.
especially with all the coverage and mlg
and this that and the other
it just took on it just became this all
of the beasts so the genesis of who i am
today
comes from racing games but it was
definitely
made into a monster by bungie so you can
blame bungie for me nice
okay so i also gearhead petrolhead
watched
way too much top gear i had a
lamborghini
bedroom wall i've had a corvette at one
point in my life
um okay you gotta give me like top
two cars that are affordable that you
wanna put in your garage that you think
you can
and then top two ridiculous way over the
top like favorites of all time
affordable cars right now less than 120
how about that less less than 100k okay
um a lot of people would probably
suspect i would say tesla um but i don't
like teslas
i think for the money you're getting
very little car
you're getting a very good appliance but
you're getting very little car
have you sat in a tesla model this i
actually haven't
it is disgusting but there's so much
panel gap it feels like i'm
sitting in an ikea showroom but like
there's less of it
there goes the uh tesla's fastest ship
yeah
that being said for for a practical
everyday car i think the tesla model 3
is fine
it's a 35 000 car plus rebates and
incentives
and it's a good sensible car for the
modern for the modern world
save the planet and all that um but
because i live in canada i need
something a little bit more practical so
i would probably spring for the volvo
v50 v70 i think it's it's basically the
wagon
okay um what's your function right now
get that wagon gotta get
extra space sit in if if we're talking
about
if you're talking about me living in
canada like as soon as you go out the
city it's just
basically the boonies right you need a
car that can last
distance and we don't have electric
infrastructure outside of the city so
you have to go to petrol um now two
mad cars that's easy porsche tai can
which is the electric porsche yep
which i love um and my all-time favorite
car
is again another porsche it's the
porsche carrera gt
oh let's see simply simply well the
looks is one thing but the
the engine note that the which is it's
it is the v10
yeah yeah yeah i respect those choices
i do are you asking me mine or not
oh god i'm listening to you gearheads
i'm i'm in awe
so for me i mean i already said it like
i've been
and this is just the american piece of
me it's like corvette for me has been a
thing forever
and just the way they've had the base
models like from
about the fourth generation i was like
oh that's kind of cool
but it was the fifth generation corvette
when they smoothed out the body
had a little better lines got rid of the
saw blade wheels that's when i kind of
like
it stuck and then i had a
sixth generation 2005 this was a nice
one
uh and it was like the dark blue and uh
and like i took it to road courses about
like
more than a dozen times that's like my
favorite hobby ever if whenever i get
back to it because
like literally driving a car around a
track like hitting the apexes and the
turns and working on like setting up my
wheels and i had racing tires and stuff
like that
and i did that about five or six times
and the timing chain broke
oh no so when i was on the track so
pistons kissed valves
like all bad things happened in the
engine so i ended up having the whole
thing rebuilt so
literally from intake all the way
through exhaust was not stock
so you'll know what i mean by this so at
the wheel horsepower you know what i
mean
yeah 500 at the wheels
so for that car it used to be much less
than that so
yeah i had um like redone redid the
headers
the the block i had it actually like
bored out
um different crankshaft in there
everything was completely done so
i had a fun car for a little while um
but yeah it sounds like it
so ended up unfortunately that was not
the first thing to break or the last
thing to break so
i had like the bad lemon and people took
their cars to tracks all the time but
all the [ __ ] happened to mine so
yeah that sucks yeah apparently i'm just
unlucky occasionally that in the
internet
but no it's like the i was like it's
been the generation of corvette that
keeps coming
and the new c8 that's that's
that that's probably my my [ __ ] car
and then there's something about sorry
no i'm gonna say and then my other
like reasonable affordable one i have an
infiniti g35 right now but the q50
actually just really like
like the q50 is kind of a nice
good balance of little peppiness because
i like the v6 but
i like the looks and the lines and
everything were you gonna ask yeah
i was gonna say the c8 corvette feels
very
overly aggressive to me it feels like
the styling's on the crack
a little bit like there was a there was
an understated aggression between the c6
c7s yeah
but but the ca it's like no let's just
dial it up to 11 yeah and turn it into
what the viper used to be
and then turn it into basically a
ferrari so yeah
yeah and then over the top cars oh dear
um
one would probably have to be
like the ferrari enzo just because it's
such a like it's so unique
in the stylings like the giant air gaps
over the front of the nose and
everything
um and that's just one of those rare
ones and the mclaren
f1 the first one
you are a man of the 90s i can tell yeah
you grew up in that same period of time
when the when the enzo came out everyone
lost their minds
i remember that but the the mclaren f1
that car i still remember like that one
against a couple and it was where top
gear actually shot it in dubai
and there's the episode where they drove
that one and that thing is still amazing
sitting in the middle the gold-plated
engine bay
no i'm a huge car nut and i've just
watched them over the years but no those
are
those are two special ones i'm learning
about my co-host this is amazing
all this stuff i didn't know about e
this is just awesome continue
so yeah sorry tangent everybody this is
a destiny podcast but i love cars too so
yeah that has to take advantage of the
gear head no doubt
yeah right right at home here man
this is a long this is a long dorm
inside of me because i know at the
minute i start talking cars to anybody
they just start slowly like walking away
nope
oh god you can tell you eat because i
got some more stuff i
have to think about no no like no we
probably talked cars for a while
so yeah it's yours i had my moment he
said i had my vote
that's not good oh yeah like for me
obviously check out gaming stuff and
then
you know obviously what he was telling
me coming on and and just
knowing about you know someone who has
that appreciation for
pvp so you know how did that
love really develop with destiny pvp
specifically
it wasn't hard because the gun play
in this game is nuts it's second to none
even
even you play destiny 1 now
even in its 30 fps state sorry pc person
elitist excited
i don't even need to do that anymore
because we haven't we're a new gen
everyone's 60 fps
so just everybody's good yeah level
playing field yeah yeah 100
and i just want to say congratulations
to consoles for having 10 year old
technology accessible to them for the
first time
anyways anyways
um yeah so so the gun play like you go
back to destiny 1
and it's still supreme um something i
i think one of the the thing i didn't
realize that you could do in a shooter
and i know
a lot of people don't play with
vibration on but i did in destiny 1
because
there was personality in every single
weapon
every blue every green every legendary
palindrome to me was
was my number one weapon because it just
felt like me and felt like my playstyle
and i'd never experienced that before in
in in a shooter or any game really i
never felt
a tool what is essentially a tool speak
to you to you
yes you know there's something
mechanical and very uh
like neanderthalic about it in
a weird way it's like how people get
attached to cars right it's the same
sort of thing it's
it's it's just there was something about
the mechanics of destiny that made me
feel like i couldn't stop playing it
and then i checked out the crucible
because purely because of the
connection to halo and bungie and all
that that was the reason i got
interested in destiny was because of
bungie
and yeah from there i was like okay
i i didn't hate it but something that
really smoothed the deal and i
re i'm so sorry to anybody who's about
to hear the story
first game 0.05
bottom dead last two kills however many
does i think
20 or something uh no yeah a lot it was
a lot of deaths
and end game reward screen september
15th i think it was like six days after
it was gonna be
galley isn't it it was ghetto are you
serious
wow and i didn't know what the hell it
was and then and then when the raid came
out when vaulted glass came out
everyone was like yeah gal horn is a
strap for this and like people are like
what the hell is this i don't have it
and i was like oh yeah i have it and my
raid team lost their minds
yo that's a crazy story because like i
said but mostly you always hear it's
like okay raindrop
hey we did the nightfall that week you
got it as a
pvp drop wow
that that's awesome that's iconic wow
how to say that that's a very unique
story man
and since then my rng has been [ __ ] so
i'm pretty sure
it's all been made up for since you got
you just you know you blew it blew it
too early
that was the big deal yeah you went to
absolutely absolutely
i was actually going to ask so
palindrome is kind of your d1 gun
sounds like i was thinking of one that i
remember
just one i mean there's exotics and
stuff but a legendary for me was always
the irene rr4 sniper
for me okay yeah yeah i did like that
that was always one for me and it was
one that it was like it was a low aim
assist
so i always like felt i felt when i hit
the shots they felt really crispy
to me and it was just one of those that
i really always enjoyed and i was gonna
ask cognito what's your do you have any
like legendaries from d1 that kind of
like stick out
yeah for me um nirwin's mercy held a
special place
for me i loved him it was a this was
before the clever dragon era
it was nervous yeah erwin was special
for me um
trying to think i was i mean now it's a
perk but yeah plan c
well that's no that's exotic i don't
count well um i'm trying to think
another legendary
oh um hopscotch program okay yeah
that had run ahead it's late hey day
yeah that had a run and um
party crasher party crasher plus two oh
god yeah yeah
just all of those a little funny name i
like was the comedian remember that
remember that [ __ ]
the flavor
yes yes there we go i got one hawk
bring back omalon snipers thank you oh
yes yes irene it's because range is tied
to aim assist but for whatever reason
irene had a really
weird bass range and then the high zoom
scope which made it feel
amazing it it reminds me a lot of the
like just from pure mechanics not
like like in terms of like how the cones
work
codes it's it reminds me of the oculus
sniper right now
um high zoom low range yes
yes similar kind of crispiness but not
obviously
because the the juice box sound effects
of the amalan stuff
yeah it was amazing oh yeah amazing
those were unique
shout out the black iron man said the
original messenger yes shot the doctrine
of passing
that one that terrifying thing in the
face what was the reason
that i was going to say the reason you
go into trials was for doctrine
oh yeah big time i have persistence and
i've got the other role it was crazy
but what was the scout real quick before
um because i was a big all melon guys
omalon scout not that one that was
but this one was like a hard-hitting
scout
casitas character because
i see this it's the other omalon one
right yeah
yeah the casitas or whatever it is i'm
saying it right but i know what you're
talking about
i was going that's what you gotta eat
um so obviously crucibles like
your bread and butter your home um and
you've had some decent grinds
you're not forgottens your lunas howls
your
potential trials passages uh do you have
any specific like
first time you went through trials or
first time like when you got that gun
for the first time what are some
like epic crucible stories like for you
what's your one of your top ones just
like a journey that you went through
in bungie's you know destiny crucible
that they built after you had halo and
then crucible what's
the big one that sticks out for you for
your kind of top crucible journey that
you went through well
well it's hard because destiny one never
really had
um these these huge long arduous grinds
for specific weapons
um in pvp um we've only really had one
which was not forgotten in luna's how
and
that to me like even with doctrine and
even with like some of the
the the trials weapons it was just a
flawless run right it's just a flawless
run
and then rng which you can knock out in
45 minutes to an hour that's not a real
grind
um the big the the most memorable to me
was was not forgotten
um because that took me two seasons to
attempt
actually three seasons i i tried in
season four only got luna
up to luna's um and even that was pretty
vindicating that was that felt good
because
in year one of destiny one i was
trash i did not like
the the the double prime primary
i didn't i didn't like the slow time to
kill although since then i've come to
appreciate what it
what it used to be i didn't like it
because i was bad at it you know
and i think people should realize when
they have bad opinions about crucible it
might be because they're not good at it
um so i knew i knew there was like i
didn't blame the crucible
for that i blamed myself i didn't adjust
to it i didn't have people around me
that could help me
work through it um the lunas hall grind
was was validating because it was
tangible progress to me
and it was incentivization and
validation to me that i was on the right
path to getting better
i was playing well with my team and i
was also dead with some really really
good friends who were still
some of my closest friends in the game
um and
that was a nice shared moment um but
really honestly not forgotten to me was
was the pinnacle experience because
i don't particularly remember the games
i just remember the long nights i
remember the queueing i remember the
the the queueing at certain hours to
avoid certain players because we knew we
weren't good enough to face them
i remember i remember literally like
writing
writing uh like a i was doing i was
still in the film industry so i was like
writing
call sheets and doing like um script
revisions and stuff like that for a
project the next day
whilst i was up at like 2 a.m wow
waiting for a match
wow like th this was definitely a
product of bad game design where
where the the glory based matchmaking
was so strict
that you only had like four or five
teams in the world on
at the same time at your level um
[Music]
but it it all added to this experience
where we sometimes you'd wait 20 minutes
for a game
and i was doing other things and to most
people that's ridiculous that that
doesn't make any sense
people would quit the game they would
say this is a joke i'm going to csgo i'm
going to valerie i'm going to all that
but i love destiny and i really wanted
this gun i've never wanted a gun more in
destiny
than not forgotten because it was
ridiculous it was so
dominant it was so powerful and
ultimately it ended up being really
really good to use
um so the day i got it i just i just
remember being very very emotional i was
very happy i was in a good mood for the
rest of the week
and using it it just became my instant
favorite weapon of all time um
so yeah that would be that would be my
my best experience my my absolute
favorite
i mean that grind was serious you know
and
i'll be under that under that meta right
like that was that was a crazy better
you know back in those times and then
that archetype i believe was 180 right
like
it was 80s were dominant so you know you
had that and those serious perks and
then yeah man so
it was a badge now that being said how
did you feel
you feel about people going up to the
kiosk at walmart and just going to pick
one up
okay i'm okay with that i'm okay with
that because because
it is well okay let's talk about it
we have to lead oh is it too early to
start drinking
i just did what are you talking about
[Music]
let's go okay let's go okay so do i just
need to pour this in a martini glass
make you feel better i am i'm okay with
people being able to pick it up
just with that alone because i do not
wish that grind on anybody i
genuinely don't that grind was rough it
was horrible even though i just said it
was my favorite
aspect of it it was most of the payoff
that made it worth it if i didn't get an
offer gone i'd be
just as bitter and i would probably not
be here i'd still be on reddit in a
comment section somewhere
spewing salt um
but i don't i don't wish that grind on
anybody
but what they did to my boy what they
did to what they did to your boy
cannot be forgiven the original reason i
made a video on this
before before i i was the size i am now
and i said that it was a magnificent
misstep how they nerfed it they nerfed
mag how to basically be a range buff
rather than a damage buff and that took
not forgotten from being a .67 times
kill
to a 1.0 it just killed it all together
because 180s didn't get any love
as a result of that and the reasoning
they gave was because you could two-tap
very quickly on
on console and i understood that not
forgotten was a real play gun console
because of
because it was a precision archetype and
precision archetypes don't suffer from
the same rubbish that normal
crucible hand cannon archetypes suffer
from on console with
with ghost bullets and a lot of blue
so they nerfed not forgotten because of
their own
incompetence with balancing hand cannons
that's the thing that really gets me is
to this day
they nerfed not forgotten because they
made all the other hand cannons feel
like crap that not forgotten was not the
issue
it was just it just highlighted the
deficiencies in the rest of the
the balancing for the sandbox um
so it became irrelevant immediately and
even though
you kind of whipped it out here and
there for you know old time's sake or
perhaps you just wanted to use something
different
it was not the same gun no nowhere near
it um
now is a 140 it has this niche use you
know perfect inner accuracy because it
is a precision frame
but it's still 140 and there are so many
better options out there
especially with random rolls mag hell
right now is a bit bugged but it doesn't
fundamentally change the time to kill
because
well it's gonna three tap because it's a
140. right so
i don't fundamentally i'm okay with
people picking it up at walmart
the walmart kiosk um
because they're they're not they're not
picking up the same weapon
that that used to be the absolute
pinnacle representation of skilled
players in the crucible
oh yeah as it's as it's a shell of its
former self you're like yeah go get the
shell
it's not what i got it's not what you
got to experience so
at this point you're like fine just
check the box you're good you're not
going to use it anyway it sounds like
so well even even if that was even if it
was the
same monster it was i'd still be okay
because it's two-year-old weapon
and we need something new yeah we do had
a very very
balanced way of looking at things
considering you were one of you know
that that special group that put in that
work
to get it in its original state so i
definitely can't respect that
yeah i'm about i'm about sharing the
love i i don't believe in
making pvp any more elitist than it
already is you know
enough enough yeah no uh i was just
gonna ask you
for crucible and stuff as well like you
started with
obviously playing working on stuff like
not forgotten you've been playing
through stuff
and you're more kind of more recent
explosion and definitely kind of your
your nature of like the the analytics
the analysis of crucible breakdowns the
going through footage saying you should
be looking here these guys could be
coming over here what's your radar doing
like breaking everything down when did
you find that that was like one
a skill set that you had and now you're
turning it into like
truly like crucible school like you
literally teach people lessons of how to
how how to play the game like when did
you see that was
like your skill set and then you know
tell people like kind of give a
description of like what you do if they
haven't seen you before
so on my youtube channel what i do is i
basically
make an academic exercise out of a
pastime which is
always um you know stupid idea um
but it is like so what i do is i
basically i i
create videos that break down the
crucible
this is not a meme this is actually how
i um
oh no i know yeah you're doing doodles
and notes the whole time it's great
yeah it's so basically i will take a
subject
that's a let's let's talk about the
two-second rule because i think that was
the most
uh that i think that's the thing people
know me before the best
the two second rule is a very simple
concept
it may it basically amounts to don't
stay in one place for too long
but i expanded upon it and i just gave
it some concrete reasoning and i just
tried to explain why it's so important
and why you should be doing it and
i guess in the process of explaining
very very basic concepts in in
in the way that i do it opens people's
minds and people seem to really
appreciate
my perspective on things i want to make
it clear right now
i'm not sure why i've blown up i just
like making this content because i like
making this content
um to me all of this is very rudimentary
it's all stuff you can see it's not
something that i was trained on or
or anything like that um but i guess
like
for me what i've realized is
through when i when i first realized
this is when i was uh
doing sherpas over at r slash crucible
sherpa which is like
destiny sherpa but for crucible um back
in the day
dr lupo ninja novell and ramblin would
stream trials
their trials carries and there was they
were active on that subreddit that's how
that subreddit became popular
and the what they would do is they
wouldn't just
you know come into fire team and we'll
take it to the lighthouse
they would really take the effort to to
coach the other person
saying okay you did this good and you
did this bad and i want you to try this
out for the next game and then
it would work and by the end of the run
by the end of the ninth
game remember when it went to nine wins
um
by the end of the ninth game this person
would be noticeably better
as a player there would be a
full-fledged member
of that fire team rather than the
liability nice so
you know me i was really inspired by
this and i you know i tried to do in the
weekends obviously got no attention
because
those three guys were the with the main
attraction so i said okay let me do it
midweek
but then i realized oh well nobody's
gonna want to play midweek because well
there's no
pvp activity to do midweek right and
then i thought okay well why not just do
it like 1v1 coaching why don't i just
say
hey let's do someone who wants let me
tell you what you're doing bad at
um and so from that that's when i really
started to realize that a lot of people
don't play with their game with their
brain turned on in the crucible and and
it's not not an
insult to anyone's intelligence well
it's literally like you're you're sad
like this
for people who are only listening on
audio what i'm doing is i'm reclining my
chairs
you just you sat like this you sat some
distance away from the
from the controller from the tv
you're playing in control you're very
laid back you're you're you're couch
potatoing basically
right right and so that's a pretty
relaxed
state to be in and when you're in a when
you're in that relaxed state you're not
focused you're not
you're not your body is not
communicating
to your mind that you're ready for
something right
so you miss things you miss little
pieces of information you miss
a radar blip you miss a heavy police
miss something in the
kill feed that that can give you
information about a situation that's
about to happen
and so what i'm trying to do is
basically just highlight
these things and just make you aware of
them because all of the
lessons i teach you in the crucible
they're not hard they're very intuitive
you could come up with them yourself
it's just about remembering it in the
moment and i think the way i word things
and i guess the way i sound too
definitely helps it helps you to
remember them
yeah i mean pretty cool because one
thing that i noticed like i said
it's it's a rare i consider like a rare
skill set because
you know it's one thing to say hey
these are the top guns or the top you
know builds or whatever
to use in in the current state of the
matter of pvp but it's one another thing
to look at as
an individual's play style and then say
hey
here's some things you can kind of
course correct here's some things that
you can kind of do to improve your game
and that's different man and it's really
it's really cool like i said
it's rare that you see it so it's cool
that you kind of curved out that lane
for yourself
and that also people respect you because
you know it help
improve their game you know they've
literally become better players as a
result
so that that to me is pretty awesome i
want to definitely shout you out for
that because
you don't see that often and it's pretty
cool i think a lot of
sorry a lot of the um a lot of the
previous like even to this day
some of the people who make youtube
videos on um
just crucible are very focused on use
this to be good or do this and you'll be
fine
they don't explain why why and
and the best youtubers i found
like there's there's a lot of us that
there's a few of us who are doing
i guess the same thing that you're
you're praising me for doing but there's
a there's a
small but growing number of people who
are doing this i want to just shout
those guys out patty cakes is one he's
probably the biggest one
uh he definitely talks about the why a
lot there's brave hero who also does a
great job of explaining the why
apathetic i'm going to say it us is one
of the best warlock players in the game
and everyone should be watching his
stuff oh i need to find him
as a fellow i gotta find out and then
there's uh
castle and also a new like somebody who
i've been working with and mentoring a
lot is uh
a guy called golden gaming um which we
make fun of because it's
about god in gaming but yeah that's not
what
it's just golden um but yeah like those
guys the
the the part of the new school of
crucible teachers
in that we teach you the why and instead
of the how because the how can be done
in all sorts of different ways that's
the beauty of destiny pvp the how can be
done
in any kind of way and it really doesn't
matter but people focus on the
the the creators that get clicks and the
creators that get clicks
are the ones saying this is the best
weapon question mark
shocked face and thumbnail
and and and i definitely know that i've
left a lot of growth on the table
because i don't do that um but
i like if i'm gonna stay true to what i
believe in then i'm gonna i'm gonna
give you the best information that i can
possibly give you
and make it unique to to my channel and
what i do
i mean that's the best thing to do
i've learned like from me from anybody
i've seen
for content try and find your space and
as you said there's some stuff that's
left on the table
the clickbaits the other things the
other like and again
not gonna like mess with anybody it's
like it's a hustle out here no matter
what you're trying to do so you gotta
find some way to make your own
but again it's like if you can find your
space as you said if you find
because i've done my own piece of the
pve site as well like my solo guides and
things of that nature
for again trying to get somebody to
understand what's going on in an
environment mine's just a little more
understanding what the
enemies are going to do yours is like
how to play a room
very different way to say how to play
room but
poker game could come up very
differently there
but yeah it's like it's when you take
that time and you're like the
having somebody take a second understand
what is about to happen
and i think that's a really cool way to
take crucibles because
what is going to happen here pause a
frame well as you said the kill feed how
many people probably don't even look at
that
like what just happened who popped heavy
like
that's gone now what super is out there
in the world now that you should be
aware of
um who like just got like three snipes
in a row watch what quarters you go
around anything of that nature is gonna
help you
and there's a lot of people that as you
said it may not be like ground breaking
or earth shattering but it's stuff that
if you start to be aware of it or if
somebody's like hey a sentence said
look at these couple things i'm gonna
try and remember these two and if it
takes my kd from point six to like point
nine
i'm going to start listening to him more
because he's got me thinking more as you
said
get more engaged there was a there was a
supporter of mine
who did put it in the in this kind of in
in a really
illuminating fashion is that i always
talk about how
the game like on my streams and
sometimes in my videos is
i say the game is throwing information
at you this game throws so much
information at you
that it is overwhelming and there was a
supporter who came into my chat recently
and said
well you're the antenna then you're the
radio antenna that helps us
hear it and see it and and that was that
was a nice way to put it
then and it was very humbling um but um
yeah like i think people's antennas
aren't
tuned to that information because as we
know destiny is
one of the best games in the world at
explaining things to you oh that's just
so clear so clear yeah
brand new player it's laid out the
silver platter
perfect descriptions very trailed manual
training you you've heard that small
youtuber datto
uh yeah i think you'll have to let me
know
yeah he makes these great guides on how
the game works but like you don't really
need them
this is good stuff this is good good
information and then um
just so i want to ask to double down
with pvp as far as like
a lot of the terminology you know
because i was getting into i remember my
startup um
first of all a very average pvp player
but i love it and i remember like you
know we had mercury's on i remember the
days of me going to the reddits and
and and seeing terms i didn't understand
right yeah like advanced
you know and it's like you know weebs
and scrims
and and then you know so break this down
these terminologies you know the pvp
culture
yeah how how do we get there what do
these be
well first of all get good yes
you got to give you got to give me terms
to break down like i need specifics here
so what is it scrims that's the first
one so that's like more control i'm
assuming the controls okay
environment scrims are the controlled
environment that
um a lot of people set up to play it's
it's it's basically a more competitive
environment it's it's
a shorthand of the word scrimmage which
is a battle
and basically what we do in scrims is we
try and
engineer an environment that's as
balanced as possible as hyper
gun play as possible because of the
variety of what destiny is
a lot of people have different takes on
diff on scrims so you see a lot of
different rule sets
not too long ago with a clan that i will
not repeat their name
they were the dominant force in the
scrim scene and they would set the rules
and also win all the tournaments which
uh integrity
but anyways
yeah anyway if there was an esports
scene we'd have problems
um yeah anyways since their demise and
very very happy demise um
there's been an explosion of people
trying not to take the mantle but just
to democratize scrims a little bit
so you've got the d2 arena which is the
biggest um like
just casual scrim scene uh you have the
face it which i think people
are more familiar with because let's
face it and it has a name
they have their rules um i've got my
rules on my community discord
server uh we've got a charity pvp
tournament happening this sunday which
is probably one of the most relaxed
rule sets we've ever seen um people have
different interpretations for
for me my take on scrims should be
let's play destiny
let's not try and make this another game
that it isn't
and what i try and focus on in dusty the
philosophy for
for our scrims is basically let's find
the best destiny players
not the best hand cannon shotgun players
okay
okay okay so people who know how to
people who know how to use
builds to make your life miserable and
abilities to
really you know make you wish you didn't
get out of bed that morning
i mean there is that's one thing about
destiny that is fairly
unique and there's some people that it's
like there are times when people like oh
you just want like white weapons in pvp
and like set loadouts and all this stuff
and you're going
there's a whole other slew of stuff in
this game that we're like missing out on
but also like what if people were like
hey no abilities and it was just like
guns only and you're like
how's the point in my character so like
at the way
yeah you can go play cs go you go play
call of duty
depending on what you're looking for but
i like how you said play destiny because
you do have abilities
sometimes they're over top it's a little
bit broken but you know understanding
how this one plays against this one
understand now stasis kind of breaks a
whole lot of stuff right now that's
another discussion but
you have you know if you see hammers
versus this that or the other and it's
like understanding
there are pieces to play against those
or understanding
what you should do when that happens as
opposed to we're just going to eliminate
like we're just going to take the eraser
to the whiteboard of destiny just leave
this little piece down here and that's
that doesn't leave quite as much to the
game that you play all the time anyway
so
i like what you said like play the game
as opposed to
make another game i like that and and
that's something i'm gonna be focusing
on
uh come the new year it's just our rule
sets and try and promote them and
just get because right now the sweat
community has uh
the sweat is a term for people who
uh don't use deodorant um
savage
it's a pretty universal term for a
hardcore player um
so you have pve sweats too like speed
runners and and grandmaster knife
players and that sort of thing but for
pvp yeah like the sweats
they definitely have a very bad rap at
the moment they're very they
there's accusations of elitism
gatekeeping all the rest of it
there's a few new guys in charge of
certain scrim communities that i do want
to highlight and i want to highlight the
work that they're doing because
right now i feel like the scrim
community the sweat community they have
a big pr problem
um the rule sets do make sense it's just
that
nobody's taking the time to explain them
guys um
so yeah what else can i uh illuminate
you on no
i guess dad that like that was that and
then it wasn't weebs or something i
think something like weebs
yeah what's that you don't know what a
weeb is no break it down
a are you aware with weebus i'm just
gonna let you fill it in
okay um a weeb
is um short for weeaboo okay
and it is a descriptor for someone who
lives breeds and shits anime
okay okay okay and and these are
typically
teenagers like under the age of 18
uh who are in high school who
have not yet formed a personality or
an original opinion um who
are very very into having profile
pictures as anime characters
okay okay okay okay usually come up with
the
shall we say most interesting takes on
twitter in response to some big creators
they are they're they're they're very
you know i'm not gonna rag on them
but they've got some they've got some
work to do
they've got some life to experience
before they actually get a real business
is it i'm getting toxic vibes is it like
it's not it's not toxic vive but i tell
you one thing the the people who hate
weaves the most
are weebs okay okay
i'm learning like i said i just do
terminologies and
stuff it's it's always cool cool
learning stuff it just you know all the
stuff that's
kind of birthed or associated with uh
destiny pvp sometimes i just thought
this is hilarious oh no i don't know
there's that's why i was like it's
awesome
there seems to be a high saturation of
of anime lovers
with destiny fans uh there's a lot of
crossover and
i didn't really i had no idea why and
then
someone said to me well destiny is
basically an anime
in terms of like storytelling isn't
super super literally gonna come
home in there so yeah yeah yeah i
believe you literally got that so
that to me made more sense but i still
don't get it
somebody's like can one be a weeb at 32
i have a friend asking
is it is it is he asking for a friend or
is he just stating i have a friend
because
if he's just stating i have a friend
yeah i was going to say i was just
saying if he's saying he has a friend at
the age of 32 i'd say that's par for the
course for a weeb
well i was like we could just talk about
crucible for like three hours i'm trying
but things have happened this week in
the game
shockingly and one of the big ones
is a gun quest came out and
it's a d1 throwback the as the crow
flies let thy talons loose
all the quest of fun want to get you
guys takes on the quest itself and we
will get to the gun
after but quest first what'd you guys
think of the golden feather quest
not quite the golden ticket quest but
that's a little different
our steve guest nomad what you felt i
thought it was interesting
um i like the puzzle nature of it i
definitely got stuck
i definitely looked at reddit i
definitely found the answers to read it
um but it was it was fun to try and
figure out like
just through the wording and everything
it felt like a crossword almost
um it was it was it was a different take
on it
the final mission was bugged for mine
and my fire team
didn't particularly like the guardian
champion quest um
because it was such a weird change of
pace from like yes
puzzle puzzle now grind yeah but then
but then glad tweeted about the the lost
sector thing and
it made it a lot more palatable it was
over in half an hour
and the final mission was pretty
interesting uh the new area in that lost
sector was kind of nice
um and then the there was loris
apparently that was very good with it
but i didn't get around to reading it
but overall i i thought it was a lot
better than like devil's ruin
you know it was unique and it was
different and it's not something we've
seen before so i liked it
cog yeah yeah man it was it was a
pleasant surprise it was um
you know for me i've been on the train
of gotta give the narrative team
damn dude this time and this season for
me
you know i know not a lot there's a lot
of things that a lot of people in the
community don't like about
y'all like this season but for me i'm
always gonna be more biased towards
when the lore is done correctly and we
all know aldrin
is a big character we all know the old
i'm sorry the crow
sir aldrin the hunter vanguard
that's jumping but you know hey i'm
going there i'm going here
so you know i i repeat is it too early
to start drinking
never it's five o'clock somewhere
somebody said
so if you want to get your k tears uh
you know hey i'm all for the movement
so i'm this is something i try to tell
fellow hunters
get ready you got to embrace your
brethren this this is
not going to be happy if crow is the old
if crow is the bad guy i'm
i'm getting you to the acceptance phase
sir no he's currently in denial
he's holding on i know he's older and i
i respect that from behind this we all
love kate
and i think shout out to paul tassie who
we had on last week he said it best
he's doing the quest and he's like i
can't believe
i i don't want to like him i don't want
to like that
100 agrees that like no they're taking
like the crow he is number one his own
guy but like the actor
who's playing him but the lines the way
like
there was one of those and it was like
the biggest pregnant pause and voice
dialogue i've heard in dusty in a long
time
and i was just like and it's so well
delivered for his
just like he's so torn inside as so what
is going on
like what he's seeing he's viewed the
way he is and he doesn't even know why
he has this little like shack up there
when you when you go to the little
offshoot you see the audience pooping
shout out to guard he's pulling continue
wouldn't shout that out what did his
little setup in by the um the the the
what was the strike the strike that we
always do with the take it yeah
did you did you analyze that rule yeah
i listened to all the stuff in there
yeah there was a bunch of stuff but no
just the way they're talking about it
and what he's going through and his
his whole delivery in this quest is to
another level
for like just a random exotic quest i'm
loving what they're doing with him so
far now granted him being 100 vanguard
i still think he's way too fresh for a
guardian for that to happen so i still
don't think that's gonna be true
because it's just a weird switch but get
ready like for developing a character
and giving him like
just emotional depth i'm so impressed so
far no absolutely absolutely
don't look you know at the end of the
day you know for me like i said i want
to see how they were going to handle it
you know also i thought it was unique to
link him to the hawk boom right
that to me was a you know a bold
decision like you know you're putting an
iconic gun
you know and this character that we want
to get you know information on and
you're combining it and they weaved it
in a way to me that made sense that i i
agree with so
ultimately for me like you said he it
was i loved the delivery
you know by by the actor i felt
the thing that hit me the most is when
he said
i know the way they look at me
yeah i did something horrible yep
would he deliver that it to me this is
the road to redemption you know what i'm
saying
it's just it's just so well done and um
yeah man
just like i said a beautiful quest i'm
loving the lore everything about it
and again i i didn't i i'm very
surprised that
hawkmoon in him was there was the way to
tie this thing in
and i got to give the narrative team
that dude so for me yeah i like it yeah
this is this is definitely like like
hawkmoon was the symbol of of
of light yes uh it's a symbol of light
in the destiny universe and
and it it's it's a gun with a lot of
positive
um association for a lot of people and
to tie
it to crow was kind of genius
like it's it's now you have to care now
if you don't like
if you don't like crow you don't like
hawkmoon it's really that simple
it's perfect they put
again fellow hunter you gotta shout you
guys out they put you guys in the spot
you're just in the spawn and and and
here's the other thing
you know the traveler is speaking
you know to him in his very way
inadvertently right
yeah and it's just to me it's so well
done and i i can't wait
to see as this thing goes on and stuff
where they go but um
yeah man so like i said the quest itself
that that's where i was at but what
about you
quest yourself now that you've got it
wrapped up yeah
no no go ahead you send it no you're
good yeah
i was gonna say the the quest for me i
love the quest
because the storytelling was actually
in front of you it wasn't hidden behind
lore
and i know there's a lot of people who
who watch this podcast in the dashing
community
who love the lore and i don't want to
rag on the lore but when you're in a
video game
and you're you're catering to a
wide variety of people the lore should
be treated as extra
to the storytelling it should be the
icing on the cake it should never
be the thing that you discover
storytelling from
in my opinion if you're in a video game
itself like you should play through
events
should we cut scenes there should be
quick time events there should be all
sorts of different things
we should see this development on screen
not off screen
yeah and i'm just liking that we're
seeing the humanization of
crow of aldrin or everyone who want to
call them
in front of us and we're it's forcing us
to to come to terms with what's
happening
this is one of the biggest things i had
an issue with beyond light is aramis
i understand her motivations i get it
trust me i
totally understand where she's coming
from i related to her story for sure
yes but who the [ __ ] is she
have we seen her before no where did she
come from we don't really know she was a
hero at twilight gap or she was a
a big part of twilight gap great
literally nobody in the majority of the
destiny community knows
about twilight gap aside from it being a
very questionable pvp map
[Laughter]
i know is this might be a bit of a hot
take but like i'm just this is this is
what you feel
that's what you feel just this is real i
mean
like this this is my thing this is my
profession for a long time with
storytelling filming tv
and when you have to go to the books to
tell to create your story on screen
preach be
[ __ ] up no preach i'm i'm with you
there i'm with you there no
even even just a kind of slightly
unrelated story
obviously we are we get a chance to
touch on it was you know with osiris and
the whole thing you know me being a big
old cyrus fanboy and people were like yo
your man got slapped around and look you
don't say oh just had to save the day
they stay in the third and i'm like
the sad part is if you actually if those
people read which they shouldn't have to
immolate or whatever it's called and
then find out what happened to segura
and find out
how dire his situation was and what he
did to again
you know this is bungie now like you
know this is great that you have these
stories
but we need that in game so now a lot of
these story things can have context good
i see you ready to
get getting over it do you know what
that that
then when we flew in uh for the first
mission of the season
he's lost he's lost security has been
killed you know what that reminded me of
somehow palpatine has returned
and i know it's just like nails it
pretty well you're like how did what
what did i miss
what what did i miss you fast yeah facts
and i had to go
read this lore and then i'm like oh
because i remember it was a big
little point of contention because
people i i was upset after i was like
but i saw the the
um the trailer and i'm like he just got
slapped in my opinion by like some
average uh hive night and i'm like this
is the great obsession how many times
have you been killed by hive knights
just asking
who's been killed all of us have been
killed by i have knights
which guardian's name put give me some
names
[Laughter]
give us some days to go with slaves
you know a couple people i'm talking
about great guardians
i'm not talking about the dudes that
just got to the tower i'm talking about
fabled guardians i was like sure i'm
pretty sure emptash quit destiny because
he couldn't get rid of one
hype look back back off focus but my
point was i just to me
again not saying it's impossible but i
just needed an explanation and until i
read the lore
what they put out of the game then it
made sense and i'm like oh okay it's
just that you guys didn't communicate
this well that's all it is because
by the time he gets to uldren he's get
he's up sagira is gone
you've already been in a weakened state
you used all your powers to try to kill
crota's children and
all this other stuff i found out that he
could use chaos reaching the other
supers which i didn't even know
he could do but back on focus that
that's pretty much what
nomad is saying where it's not a good
job when you don't
say these things or show represent them
in game
and we got to go read subtext and find
out all this other stuff
is to get the full context of it
absolutely i mean
it is it is it is uh a devil of their
own making though for bungie because
there's so many characters so many story
lines so many different threads
it's it's hard to keep up with it all
and develop content for it on screen i
totally understand and respect that
which is why i think another thing that
people have been calling for is
resolution
is just like let's tie some of these
things together so it makes your job
easier
it makes our job easier trying to keep
up with it i'm sure
you know people like biff and martha and
adam you know
they're going to have less content if
they go that route but uh
you know would we'd have a richer story
and we'd be a lot more invested
if that were the case and i still stand
by my theory side note
uh i forgot who agreed with me on this
was so funny i was like we all know the
real reason why security is dead
and i was like the voice actress is
unavailable where they have to
yeah this is typical bungie this is
vintage bungie like
they they hire these very high profile
voice actors and actresses
who are also doing multiple other
projects and the thing with bungie's
they want you to come in a lot
do tweaks do edits you know what i'm
saying because i know you know what i
knew it was it was
the deal e when he came back in season
the dawn and we didn't see segura at all
and i'm like wait a minute how where is
sagar like what's going on yeah that was
a weird one
yeah that's why i was like yeah the vice
actress is she's busy right now but
continue continue
the whole thing i don't even know where
they were
yeah no it's like oh no the storytelling
i missed i missed a week we missed the
weeks i had to get that
no you're totally fine because like the
storytelling
i was happy to see and this is one thing
i wish they would have done for
what you just said when we logged in for
beyond light and we got the animated
storyboard
we played goat like cognito and i played
through ghost of tsushima
they do animated kind of i say animated
storyboard i don't even know if that's
the right term from a film guy could be
butchering it so sorry
but um concept art concept art okay
there we go they use those like animated
art pieces to
tell a story and they did that in ghost
of tsushima with these like
legendary side quests you'd go through
and
they explained so much in like a brief
time but it is it's like
you're staring at the screen as you said
it's on screen
same thing as we're going through this
mission you go into the little side room
and you see where he's got a sleeping
bag set up and the curtain that was
draped over him when he woke up he's
like
it was weird but it's like i felt like
it was my like the sheet that he was
covered
when he's dead like he kept it and you
see that and you're like
those little nuggets that you get from
in-game
stuff is true but when you log in and
you're like why was osiris in trouble
he lost he lost seguir and you're going
i'm sorry
where did that happen and again if they
could have done just a little animated
bit of
you know here is him here's him using
all his powers seguir
does what at least cognito i think like
basically sacrifices sort of sacrifice
to save him
yeah and you could show that and be like
he's not in the best place and now he's
down there doing stuff he shouldn't be
doing
yeah you could have showed that pretty
briefly to give a recap of what people
may have missed and that would have been
amazing one last point and we got it we
got to talk about again we missed last
week
um you know the big the controversy you
know as far as uh
i think it's a joke because there's no
controversy but you know as far as the
whole say
in osiris relationship and like if
the sadly the lore written in these
grimoires often
it's there you know it's there and what
a key thing that's
missed right there was one before where
osiris was i mean
uh saint was leaving notes or whatever
in his ship
then this one when he goes into you know
the
the moon and where crotis i mean which
of course stuff got killed he's doing
his solo mission seguir is like look you
are too weak you've
you've been you've been around the whole
universe exploring why all those planets
have disappeared
right you went to zavala to ask for um
to help initially zavala says look all
our resources are
towards um europa we cannot help you
he then goes on by himself as he goes
deeper into the moon and his keeper
wherever he's at
segura's like you're in a weakened state
i don't think it's a good idea he's like
no
you know um this is my one shot to
eliminate all of them
you know the crota's kids and this one
and the supplicant and all this and
zebra wrath all this is there in one
spot
and he goes hand that's when i find out
he can use all these powers right
he gets everything then the supplicant
comes and then that way it gets serious
and
he's about to lose his light now at that
point
he then says something very key he goes
to like yo
i need i'm not we're not going to make
it out of this yeah you
like christmas cyrus cigarette you go
you know i'm gonna die whatever
you tell whoever no he goes please tell
saint and he's about to get into this
very emotional thing
and she's like no one of us is gonna
make it
and then she does the self it is so
beautifully written
right so that was the first hint you
know and it's been these little
trails of of this relationship stuff so
again
it shouldn't be a surprise again if it
was more uh you know probably more in
the game stuff like that
but i just thought that was something
that it was all there
and that for people to bug out about
that it's it's a non-issue because it
technically was there but i i had to get
it it's
it's it's lose-lose for them because no
matter what if you do any sort of
if you do any sort of
non-heteronormative
representation right non-non-white
representation
right non-any normal representation
people will lose this [ __ ]
it doesn't matter if it's in lore if
it's an on-screen people are going to
lose this [ __ ] regardless
that being said you know season of dawn
was literally the story of how osiris
tried to break
time and space to save one dude wasn't
that enough of a [ __ ] hint
exactly my greatest failure was this and
then the last point
where now let's get in game right when
we go to the mission
again he's going to the moon they say
hey osiris is in trouble go save him
okay boy you go down deeper
there's a part where he tells you the
player
look if i don't make it please tell
say again your dying wish you tell that
to your loved one
right that's what that is right so then
your ghost nathan
wasn't nolan north whatever no no
you tell them yourself and again
connection can we just keep the bro hug
on screen for the love of yeah
i mean you talked about that yeah you
said that a long time ago like he
came out of time we never got to see
them
shake hands hug it out nothing he just
was like
tower didn't even like stop by the
sundial be like
dude love you man thank you very much i
gotta go set up shop you hold out here
it's been a while zero and i'm like how
do you do that so these two iconic
characters
i still never know that was such a
hopefully now that
everything is out there i'm sorry again
why don't they put them two together
together yeah i i think i think it's
coming i think now because
again of the backlash because everybody
was putting the tea leaves together like
look i'm the biggest osiris fanboy
that's my man i started putting it
i'm like yeah these two are really close
i was like okay i get it no doubt that's
my bad whatever
so but the thing is it's like
i guess there was some backlash on
twitter on social media
and people like there's no way you know
dude bros out there there's no way bro
you know what it's just friends these
people these people
live a very sheltered existence they
don't understand they're bad at a
fictional character having a
relationship okay
whatever i think i think a lot of
people's perceptions were shattered
because
saint 14 is like yeah the epitome of
yeah and it turns out he's a massive
bear you know
like they've never heard the term bear
in real life
i just have some questions though and
i'm not sure we can talk about it
because i know they're kids who watch
this
how does their relationship physically
work i know where you oh yeah
last time we literally got into it last
episode two or two weeks ago we were
like we were trying to figure out who's
the big spoon in the little spoon
so we were oh my gosh we went into this
already yeah we would you want there to
be a spoonie's metal
i know cause the thing is my gut is
because he's an exo right i know now we
do a real deep door
live you know relationship board we have
to take a break
take a break here we go deep diving um
my assumption but even my assumption is
wrong because
he's an exo right so
unless because then the writer said that
they've always been
both of those two right and i'm like
okay
so if that's the kick did he did osiris
know him
prior to becoming an exo doesn't seem
like it because he's 14 he's on
four generations of 14. right so that
part i agree i don't
know that part i know we know x's don't
lose their sentience
we know even just with the exo stranger
that there is a
um like a lot of like
there's a lot of characters still there
there's still a human there
right um so naturally they're subject to
the same development
that normal humans are going through
like they'll learn new things still
right
they'll can't touch these things have a
sexual relationship let's just get it
out there
yeah i don't know if exo can have a
sexual relationship i think it's
strongly implied that our guardians are
asexual
as well right that's what yeah that's
okay but this seems to break that
maybe it's just a pure emotional
relationship i don't know maybe
to like platonic to like level 12 to a
point of may not
he left you're being left the notes in
the ship that said my fiery bird
he could he got the notes i'm saying
platonic's the wrong word i mean i mean
more but as you said like
it's an emotional connection not as much
physical but that's still
to a point of like love between those
two and a connection to where it's like
it's an un you know you know it's right
or die
type i mean they're those they're that
for each other and that's
shouldn't be equipped like the that type
of relationship for guardians as you
said if they're asexual when they get
reborn all the time and they got exo
bodies and stuff like
dudes anatomy work together who knows
but it's like are they still laying in
bed together like
spooning 100 percent like are they
snuggling
at best sounding kevin he said it best
he said can we just say that love
transcends any sort of physical
absolutely yeah absolutely you're right
that's absolutely
beautifully said brother beautiful
unless you have an anime profile picture
on twitter
oh somebody somebody said it earlier
they're like he's an exo he's got the
vibration setting right or something
oh my god you're stupid
how did we go from something so
beautiful to absolutely
we missed a week so we had to talk about
all these things but again
the cool thing yeah because i mean i
mean the
the same now okay
pay atlantis is like elsie's exo body
though and everybody's like
yeah it wouldn't matter
hot for her it doesn't matter what yeah
yeah elsa got the curse
but um what i was to say is but yeah it
was shout out to the i forgot the
the narrative teams uh the writer and um
what you call it basically had it when
he revealed it and he basically said
look you know we
wrote them this way for a long time and
it basically shattered
all that dude bro stuff that is no way
possible that kind of stuff
and that was cool to see you know and um
at the end of the day like i said i
don't change that he stood god to me
still my man like ain't nothing changed
for me like
still the greatest warlock i'm lit so
it's just funny to see people get
emotional but also the positive out of
it was
so many people rally behind and shout
out to that artist you put me on to
who did the most amazing yeah oh
my the most beautiful picture of them
like
i was like wow that is really well done
like
really yeah i've followed her for a long
time hers is always a very
cool style um yeah i'm actually working
with her on something but yeah
oh okay top secret explosive it it's
like
not anytime soon but yeah okay
so yeah i was like but we go through
this is this is like i know random
tangent but this is what this game can
do
for those who are like into it this long
and pay attention to the lore and all
these things that we seem to know about
the story
again if it's plastered in front of you
like not all things can be there but the
big stuff like that
yeah put a little bit more in front of
us and you're gonna have a much more
engaged community who understands where
you're going with the story who gets the
little nuances
it's like there's it's for me when i've
watched more tv shows and stuff
more recently as it seems to be this
like
you watch like network television you
get these like you know character
villain of the week and now
you see different styles of telling
stories to where you get like
it takes eight episodes to do certain
things yes
and it's like you know more on like
cable tv and stuff like that and the way
hbo does like game of thrones earlier on
but
you get more of the nuance of like the
characters and the little lines that
they say and the little things that they
do to build
depth to a character and i've really
liked some of the
not all tv is great but it's like some
of those
more detailed longer stories and i like
that style of telling a story and i wish
they would do more of that
they have so much as you said under the
surface of destiny
that they could do amazing storytelling
in this game but they just sometimes
miss that opportunity i honestly think
it's just resources
i mean that's fair too but i think it's
not that big i don't i
i don't think i don't think it's
resources it seems like management
priorities
because bungie does have deep pockets we
know this being that you brought that up
i think that's a perfect segue together
what are you going to talk about oh
we because we already finished off no
because we have to talk about hawkmoon
the gun
itself yes which is a big point of
contention
i had to do it it's finally time
speaking of
speaking of deep pockets i'm doing
everything in my power to not buy those
ornaments
oh my god i need them i need them in my
life
look kind of crispy man so
uh thoughts on the gun itself it's
functions
and just like the way the new gun works
i wanted to get your thoughts get no mad
no you guys speak first because oh
you're right you actually ready for the
fireworks i
mean i need to hear what you guys think
of it uh
your first i asked i'm first oh lord all
right here we go this is what
this is what the people been waiting for
we've been sitting on this for a while
this
hot topic shout out to forte who called
my phone when the hawthorne came
out which is kind of hilarious um look
here's the deal
um for me and i said i state my position
on the gun itself you know for what it
seems right now
obviously the precision hits and then
you get that last thing which is the
para causal shot
which does the extra damage and stuff
like that then we have the unique
nature of an exotic with random roles
right so that's a whole new bag of thing
now let's get it like i i'm i'm going
black i'm ready i'm ready
here's the thing the point of contention
before
this whole reveal was you know luke
smith came on the post
and said hey pork moon is coming back
but guess what people is not going to
have any damage perks
this is what this man said i have it
documented we we have it on screen
this man said this right so under his
own words
and what he said all i said was
i'm willing to see what they do with the
weapon right
thus we had the point of contention
which he bond test and forte
eloquently stated which i understand
everything they are saying
because they're hawkmoon fans and they
say look in order to keep the essence of
the weapon
it should come back with damage dealing
perks and if it
doesn't don't call it hawkmoon
i agree but that's the part that seems
to get missed right
i agree right all i all cognito was
saying is
being that luke smith said this it was
not going to happen it was going to be
something completely different
and we reimagined right under those
words
all i said was well let me just see what
they do with it
because at the end of the day they may
do something creative
it may be cool and that's it so when the
gun comes out
and shout out to e4 you know sending me
the joint sending me the
the data mind or whatever it was we
found you know they came out
and i'm like oh damage dealing perks
i'm like you lied luke smith like like
not that i'm mad that he lied like
look at the end of the day this is what
the fans want i'm happy you guys get
mostly the spirit of the weapon right so
being at the damage so now it's like
there's no argument to be had because
there's nothing he didn't do what he
said he was gonna do
so there's no argument now now it just
comes down to how you know how much
does the hawkmoon hardcore like what
happened
and that's it but as far as me it's over
because
he didn't do what he said he was gonna
do which was not give it damage perks it
has damage perks so that's where i'm at
with it i was just like yo
interesting cool you know i want to see
how it does in pve with the extra shot
looked at your powerful
i want to see how um you know the random
roles how that gets applied how do we
acquire that that kind of stuff and
that's it but false obviously this
office like
they didn't do what they said they was
going to do so that's to discuss for me
but i'll leave it to you because people
are coming at my line like yeah
what do you think cog and i'm like i'm
not mad about anything
there's no argument that's where i'm at
with it so
continue so for me when it comes to
hawkmoon
it was a very specific thing it was
holding aces your two random bullets
that would do
what it did now does the gun
sound crispy absolutely love the sound
of the gun
sounds honestly really really good if
it's at least one in my mind i remember
it's at least what in my mind i remember
the gun sounding like in d1 i haven't
played d1 in a while but it sounds
pretty good
um but when it comes to
the way it functions and this is what
our main argument was
you could even still have damage perks
on it
but it was like my question is why still
call it hawkmoon
if it's got these like para causal
building perks now and then you get one
giant damage shot in the end now there
may be lore in there about hawkmoon that
i don't know you guys said it was a
weapon very much tied to the light and i
understand like the crow
and birds and feathers and hawks i get
the connection of what they're going for
so i see where it worked
but also it's like you take a gun that
was like just kind of a random
it was mostly pve or pvp is where that
thing was mostly used before because it
was
not so much a pve weapon hand cannons
primaries are tough
and it was all about the random shots
and it was like it felt good most of the
time and it was a good hand cannon
every so often you got that one you were
like damn and then every blue moon you'd
get the two or you're like
and it was the double tap and it fell
really good but most of the time the gun
still felt good you just had those
moments where sometimes it was a two-tap
and that was part of the whole luck in
the chamber and holding aces and it was
the
idea you had those perks working
together
now i've heard it described very much as
now a very high skill
skill weapon you gotta hit six crits but
that second one can almost
one tap body somebody with like 280 body
damage if you have that
pure seven stack which is insanely
powerful
you put that in a highly skilled
person's hands that's lethal which is
really cool
but my biggest issue is like it doesn't
function remotely the same way
oh he's bad how do you know about this
i'm bad we're talking no i'm just saying
like
it's it's a very different feeling
weapon so
now the lore tie-in may be there but for
me it's like why can't this just be a
different hand it has parallel shots
this i mean this is my thoughts yeah
don't let it out bro
brother i'm educating i'm learning i
i was like and that's why i was like i'm
not the expert on the lore and i'm not
going to claim to be but it's like you
have something now with para causal
shots you're charging this thing up you
have this thing
it's a connection with the traveler why
does that have to be a gun that like
somehow we're like rebuilding from the
top like the lore is kind of cool behind
it but the function of the gun still
throws me to call it hawkmoon
so you like it [ __ ] hawk bird this is
this this this
it could be any other name any other
name honestly at this point
but it's just like for me that's like
they could have made something
else have this like connection to crow
and be its weapon as opposed to a d1
that doesn't have the same perks and
this is just like me probably having a
stupid hang up at this point
and i'll admit that my me accept this
phase
that's the first time you ever invented
that no but i'm proud of that and that's
the thing but it's also it's like it
it's one of those where it's also the
idea is like we're in destiny 2
how about a new weapon as well if you're
gonna make like
perks that function completely
differently give me something different
so that's
that's my main thing i haven't used it
that much i used it a little bit i got
to practice and
again my crucible skills are only okay
need to take some tutelage from our
guest
but um i gotta ask you a question before
we pass it to the
kind of condition yeah yeah this is us
working through it bro we're working
through it right now right
so like no man's over there like
yeah this is my friend
we have to work through things so let me
let me ask you so
when you when you saw the para causal
shot right and you found
out it was damaged right so a part of
you says
that's cool but that a hawkmoon right
that ain't enough
it's not a hawkmoon it's not that it's
not enough it's not that that's not an
exotic perk when you can see a damage
hit for
what i hit like 53 000 damage with the
primary handgun i was like holy [ __ ]
like that was huge but i was like
unhappy though that like doesn't even
feel good inside that dude like this is
a powerful
exotic thing okay one strong part of
hawkmoon was the random nature of the
weapon
you wanna do you wanna one tap somebody
that's what this all i can honestly tell
you i don't think i have
one that's all listen you know what that
one
i'll tell you i don't think i ever one
tapped somebody because i don't ever
think i had them both hit with the same
one
the opportunity that at eddie ted you
want to roll it dice like a slice
honestly it doesn't have to double it
was fun to just two tap sometimes
i never got the one hit i don't think i
would remember one
but it was more the random nature
because it was holding aces and luck in
the chamber it was those two combined
that made it what it was
and you could literally hear the bullets
sound differently
now you're like you're building this
buff up slowly over time
now granted for skilled players they're
probably going to enjoy it even more
because they can't and for balance
i get call it something else that's just
me
so i'm gonna leave it there it could be
hard somebody said it in chat i'm gonna
rename the title of my video to not moon
whatever it is but yeah
like like i love the quest it was cool
like the weapons unique like the
building of the damage
it's actually now again it's an exotic
and it's a primary
so pairing that against many other
exotics in the heavy slot and other
things that's still no match that's
going to be used
but it's cool but it shouldn't be called
and that's just where i'm going to leave
my piece of it you know your
your fellow hawkboon brother uh who you
both attacked me viciously
he has now joined the side of i'm happy
with what they did
well then i'm on a separate side than
him so that's no i just want to let you
know where your brother's
at that's fine so but it's just like for
me
it's a cool gun i like the story you
went through for it the quest was
amazing i like what they're doing with
crow i understand crow and hawk and
birds and feathers
get it all just just stop cool call it
hawkmoon call it anything else that's
all
this is amazing okay so we
first of all i just want to commend your
uh your stubbornness
on this particular this is your hill to
die on clearly
apparently and um
i i would i would i would encourage you
to climb off the ledge
because this is this will this is going
down a path you you can't return from
you you're missing out on the joys of
what is
and is now objectively hawkmoon
i don't know oh i i understand your
position
i understand it and and and i i applaud
your principle but
shit's changed okay
and it's time to it's it's time to
accept that your kids have grown up
they've gone to college i love nobody
you're coming back every anytime you
want to come back
you keep on talking people gonna have to
get that approval first on the internet
he said no no no he's gonna have to have
his people speak to all people before he
come back on this show
this is great i just wanted i just want
you to know that
you know it's okay for vegetables to
taste good now
it's okay to not like sugary foods
anymore oh
it's okay we're doing this now yeah we
do it this is the crowd
this is the
it is it is important to realize that a
mid-life crisis is a real thing
and that you will want to buy a porsche
you will have to forsake the corvette
and you want to do the porsche
um but and it all starts with little
signs little signs like the one we're
experiencing today in front of a live
audience where
you are admitting freely that you cannot
love
this child because it is
if nothing else my stubbornness got this
blind this monologue here
out of nomad and it is worth every
minute of it so keep going
i'm just gonna say that you know this is
gold you did adopt it
and i understand where you're coming
from it doesn't look like you doesn't
feel like you
but there is still time to give it a
nurturing loving home
and i think you ought to because
hawkmoon in my
heart take of an opinion which shouldn't
mean much but somehow it does
let's go is the perfect 140.
break it down break it down could you
wait so are you implying
that with these changes lord norman your
lord now
lord know man that that somehow this gun
could potentially be equal or better
than its original state
that budget could somehow have crafted a
way to like please that
to say that as a pvp player
as professed scum of the earth the fact
that
hawkmoon's unique trait of having
damage stealing perks or damaged or
having a huge
damage boost is deterministic and based
on how good i am on a certain day
makes me very happy i think that's an
improvement
i do want to ask you actually no i just
want to ask you about your thoughts for
an exotic random roles good question
what do you think about this
this is weird this changes destiny for
me yeah because
i don't know how to feel about this
because i loved having the consistency
of an exotic it's an exotic
it's a wild right it's supposed to be
absolutely wild it changes the way you
play the game
but now we're adding another layer on
top of that
like i understand the customizability i
know that we're moving more towards the
mmo side of the mmo fps
with the stasis subclass and the trees
and everything and then you have random
roles on top of exotics which makes it
even more
by the way i'm not looking forward to
that with armor yeah
wait no we already kind of have that
with armor with stats and everything i
don't like that
personally i think this should be always
high stat but you can get 59 ex
drop exotics which i don't know that's
still pissing me off yeah
um but for for weapons it has the
potential to make a good gun
great a bad exotic good or a
ridiculous exotic even
more ridiculous which i think is the
case with hawkmoon because
you pair that with opening shot yep
you're not missing a gun you're not
missing your first shot ever again it's
huge
that's huge yeah with the max stability
as well for for controller users
it's going to be the de facto gun in the
crucible one
when we get random rolls with it yeah i
mean i think you said it
very well i think that's the uncharted
territory we're all in right now right
you know this introduction of random
role on an exotic
and i'm in the same boat like i don't
know how to feel about it
there's a part of me that says like you
said you want that consistency that
static
you know nature of something that's
supposed to be already amazing
versus you know this kind of potentially
cool thing but then again what if you
get the bad
version of the like like versus like you
said you don't get to open this shot one
or you get it
i don't know how i i gotta see it i
don't know if i get a
sniper exotic that's got hip fire grip
on it i'm gonna lose my mind
if i if i get uh if i get whisper of the
worm with hipfire grip instead of
any i'm gonna just be like no no this is
oil this is awful
but yeah if you get a hawkmoon that can
also run surplus and you're running
around not using your abilities and your
that almost turns hawkmoon if you don't
use your abilities almost into like
delay lock at that point
um surplus at that point has potential
it was like but you said opening shot
just your first one every time like dude
hello first shot
hello going to be amazing yeah 100
it's it's the thing that really like i
understand why they're doing it
it's definitely a testing it's a test
bed for future exotics yes
i don't know if they're going to if
they're going to astroturf the the
previous exotics and reintroduce them
with random
roles uh justin saying uh random role
yotune wen
that's captain bread himself right there
that's that already know
well let's focus on getting a yotun
catalyst with insane tracking first
oh before before the random rules
catalysts everywhere with uh with random
role exotics
you're gonna extend the longevity of the
game
but i'm just concerned that there isn't
enough deterministic sources for exotics
to begin with for this to be a good idea
yeah go ahead no no i'm just saying
unless they
do you think maybe they like
zero hour it in the sense of you know
you
i saw one thing i just don't know if you
guys want me to say it let's do it
i mean i'm all for this boy basically
the only thing i saw is that we are
rerunning that final mission
on harder difficulty yep to have a
chance for it
i was just about to say that is that
like a once a week drop do you run it
seven thousand times until you get the
one you want how does that work
because i mean theoretically there's
certain things like we would like this
for other stuff too
and honestly i love the way they're
doing the lost sectors like i need to go
get an exotic helmet
those are really cool i love what they
did now granted i will say for the lost
sector's random tangent and talking to
my brother
for somebody who's not great at soloing
they don't have a way to get those
exotics right now zero
which is a problem now you could have a
really low chance to run with a group
and i could run
like my brother like with those lost
sectors on like 12
like maybe 1280 it's a little bit higher
as a group but solo you're like next to
guaranteed
some variation but if you can't do
something solo that's challenging
yeah period there's no other there's no
random chance at all anywhere
that i feel like does need looked at me
as a solo player i love it
yeah because i sat there and i was like
12 50. it's just for the quest i was
like
i went through like it was whatever
concealed void i think that day
five minutes four champions lockout four
minutes yeah i'll finish it this time
let me see if i get an exotic
i think i got two sets of boots or
whatever it was that day and
i finished it up on my own but it's like
i've done the 1250s and i've practiced
them for the average player they may not
be like yes
i don't know what it's like to face
champions and set up my loadout right
dude do you have xenophobia
if you're a new player right now dude
sun setting i'm trying to find loadouts
for this stuff i was looking for a void
scout rifle
bro i felt let me one i had to go yo
that's what i realized how
barren the loot pool was because i'm
like yo the stuff that i need some of
this is sunset most of this is
i was there was one i was looking for
like a ark something was it an auto or
i was just like yo or a scout and that
guy was like
that's it yeah thank you i was like yo
that's it and i'm like i don't even have
i think i must have broke it down a
while ago
so it really highlights exist
yeah yeah that's true too but i'm trying
to get my light level destroyed
i'm not that good i'm not e he is the
the nightfall
soloist the dungeon soloist that's what
he does
yeah little on me you grab you know grab
me a five team coordinated effort
i'm in there i'll knock it out now the
pressure's on me to get these champions
out of here the other presence of me do
officially and then
the thing that's pissing me off is you
stun them they can shoot you when you're
stunned
you get i'm getting lashed by 1280s i'm
just like
cool i cannot tell you how much i
cannot stand some [ __ ]
this is about to make me like let's go
let's go i don't know
any champions are designed in theory
may be okay one right i hate and that's
a strong word but it's fitting for this
know what you're gonna say overload
barrier getting their health back
just annoys me so much overload
especially
because captains overloads need to die
overloads suck
but over i was watching them in what is
it exodus garden i think it's called
it's the
fallen cosmodrome one mm-hmm and i was
in there and it was like the first
overload captain you get to and i was
working out on 1280 and it was just like
streaming and i was like practicing
i eventually got it done but i can't
tell you how i watch him go
he teleported like six times and i just
looked at him once
and i'm like i'm sorry what
oh so frustrating no i can't like
champions
i don't love overload
here's this guy coming at you you have
to stop him
you can retreat if you need to but his
health doesn't come back and you can
make that progress
and you can understand it oh i staggered
this guy
oh i sneezed the wrong direction health
comes back it feels like they've done a
line before you see them
yeah do what it feels like they've done
a line before you've seen them yeah yeah
yeah my main issue is i feel my my
major thing i'll even deal with that i
know you don't like that part but
barrier servers are another thing
oh yeah that's enough i don't feel it's
fifth i stun them they're still
able to shoot like that to me is a bit
much like they at the company
it can't be free true but i mean i think
i feel like it's not enough of a window
from the stun line
there's times where the stun happens and
they're still able to get the shot off
right and you get one shot and killed
and i'm just like oh it's very
inconsistent yeah
i mean you've got minotaurs they're like
mid slap and you're dead and they're
stunned and you're like how'd that work
yeah and i'm just like here we go but i
mean it is what it is no it's like i
yeah champions seem to be sticking
around yeah they're not going away
but i don't love their implementation
currently in
multiple ways it's like i sat there and
eventually worked through but i was
using the
cold snap grenade the one that travels
along the ground you don't know how many
i
missed trying to hit that damn captain
because it's gonna trail to it but he
warps
dusk field grenade that's field okay
here's the issue with the dustfield
grenade
as it continually taps the 1280 their
health goes back so fast you can barely
kill them
if you're by yourself and you're using
something small if you're using like a
primary to try and kill an overload with
dustfield
the way it like tags them and as it
continually taps them it like it stops
the stun
that was why i switched to the other one
because it would hit them and stop
they wouldn't do anything and then i
could i ended up using lament to just
smash them anyway
but like the dusk field i watched the
video even online and it kind of
happened to me too when you throw that
one
it's staggering them but it's like also
untriggering like taking them out of
stagger
so then their health is coming back
almost faster
and it may have been just a weird
circumstance but i've seen some weird
stuff with overloads and dust field and
i know it's not consistent the the
stasis thing to extend
yeah slowed effects i don't know if you
guys have that yeah that's an aspect we
all do
oh okay okay i didn't know they're
fragments sorry because i i use that one
well i mean i don't really encounter
once i get them in the end
they're usually good so yeah it's a
i want to just i just want to go back to
something you said mantis uh
just the is
is if 1250s cannot be soloed by new
players for these exotics
that's a bad thing i'm not sure that it
is
i think that for us for
all three of us right now we are
objectively some of the best players in
the game
because we're talking about it and like
having a podcast and like we're involved
in community
you're a youtuber like we make content
for this game and so
people look to us for advice and
guidance and all that
so we have ability that the general
populace does not so for us
you know perhaps we might be over
correcting on that a little bit i feel
like sometimes
when we have these discussions you have
people who say it's not difficult enough
and then there's other people who say
well we're the exception so it should be
a little bit easier for everyone else
and i think the truth somewhere in
between 1250 to me
first of all is not particularly hard to
get to 12.50 if you follow the powerfuls
and the pinnacles that's
very easy now it just takes time
secondly
the the the challenge itself for 1250s
is staying in cover
it's not going up going up and forth and
being particularly specked out for your
builds um you could go in there with a
pretty vanilla loadout and only have
things for like overload and barrier
right for one of the lost sectors um for
if match game is a thing then that ramps
up the difficulty
1280s is where it gets really
challenging for the solar player
that's right that's that's where i think
the challenge is disproportionate to
solo players who are not
also involved with with with the
community and up to date all the latest
mods and strats and all the best
to me the question is when you look when
you're bungee and you're looking at
these activities
do you have a base difficulty in mind do
you do you look at what is the average
difficulty what is the average
completion rate of a raid
what is the average compression of an
eiffel what is the average completion
rate of a strike where is the average
difficulty
right and how do you account for that
for these lost sectors
versus the more philosophical nebulous
discussion how worth it how
exotic should an exotic feel no that's
where that's where me and you are in
pocket right there
yeah no that's where i kind of reel my
emotion back in because look i'm gonna
be
shout out to justice in the chat because
i'm very jealous he's got
my favorite warlock uh bug-eyed exotic
that i still don't have yet
of course yeah oh bro i ran to 1250 like
12 times this thing will not drop
so then when it finally comes it's 1280
and i'm like
i can't beat this 1280 it's killing me
right now
i just don't have the load i have
certain weapons that are great in
certain spots of the entire encounter
right the certain spots where i could
just lay back without break prime and
just
rip through um hydras and bosses even
with
anti-barrier and it's just wonderful and
then there's you know the
our friends the overloads who run run
you down and then it's like
um you know i'm saying so it's certain
loadouts or certain things you know that
i can do so
i ran it and i'm just like yo this thing
is not dropping
and i'm just like it was just
frustrating me that i
i can't get it but there is a part of me
get back to my man no man
that's like you know what this is making
me
value this exact like when i get this
thing
like that's going to be my bug-eyed dawn
of course
like because i bled sweat and tears for
this you know
so i do like that because i do feel that
there is a part of destiny the last i
don't know a couple of years i say about
a year two years
where they just give like two yeah they
breed appearances
like when they just giving out these
exotics as soon as the season pass is
given to you like here you go
exactly i've even complained about that
too 100
i can't stand when you log in here's an
exotics and you're like
why is it an exotic you just took the
value out of it by giving it to me
going through the weapon quests and
believe me it's like from my perspective
i love the lost sector grind like the
way the 1250s feel the challenge i go
through
i've knocked out i've started work on
the 1280s starting to knock those out as
well and for me that feels good
i'm just like i'm trying to like and i'm
with you it's like some exotics should
be
hard to get i get it i was like and if
you take a 1280
and i have somebody with me maybe it's
an even smaller chance
but it's still that's going to be a
challenge with that other person
i'm and i'm with you it's like it's
tough because for me i go through 1250s
i've been lucky i've had a lot of drops
i've had two icefall mantels i've had
like more boots than i know what to do
with like
my exotic drops from these things have
been stupid and i don't understand that
i gotta be the rock this is the
disrespectful part when i'm running
the 1250s or whatever right they don't
even give me an exotic something they
gave me a blue and a coconut smile
and i'm like you cannot do this this
disrespectful
like i just did all this and you gonna
give me the blue with the coke and it's
like come on man do you want to try that
what you think
of that i know right can you give me
some fries but
give me something with it like that part
i was like
we gotta work on the rng part though
like because if i'm doing a 1250 i know
there's
people that's less skilled the 1250 is
going to be feel like the 1280
to you know take to them you know what
i'm saying so i just want that that to
get
in there you know because i only the
only one that dropped it my first time
was the necratic
grip my first time doing it it dropped
well you still got the good one
already i want my i need your john your
fire swords
oh man it's gonna transform
top tier um what you call it uh
dawnblade for me i i i can't wait to i
got some builds in my mind i want to do
and i can't do it yet but that's what i
just want them to fix the drop rate a
little bit
yeah it's like i don't know if they do
like a checklist or like some type of
protection like
if you clear 1280 like three times
probably should be an exotic
yeah where's the protection i was like
and that yeah the kind of the drop
protection of
and again but yeah it's like you log in
a different day who knows does
everything ray said is it the lost
sector itself do you have to come back
for
who knows and that's why i was like i
don't know the right
balance and that's where it's tough for
me to say for me i walk through like i
was farming the 1250
for champions for the hawkmoon quest
five minutes bam bam bam bam knock it
out log out go back do it again i was
like
i had that thing down to a science and
it was like fine cool all right
and i was like and i got most of the
1250s to that level
1280s definitely more nuanced slower
that's a thing
and for the love of god heavy ammo
synths win so guys sometimes
oh my god
you have heavy armor finder now i was
heavy about everything no i have every
amplifier i'll be putting them files on
fact
yeah but it's like and that's like for
me i sit there and i make the guide
but then i talk to somebody from another
perspective and they're like
it pisses me off because it's the only
place to get them and i'm like i don't
know how to balance that because for me
i can march that over and over and over
and i'm eventually gonna get it for
somebody else it's like it's out of
reach
and it to them it's like it's not there
and i'm like but for your stay
also for me and i've preached about this
for however many episodes of this
podcast
i want exotics to feel exotic i said
that two years later we did
this long ago and if when exotics
don't feel special what's the point
so it's this weird judge's scale of i
don't know how to balance at all
if it's out of reach and you want it
wouldn't that just encourage you to get
a ladder i mean talk about it
it's that's why i made that that's
literally why i made the guides because
like i know people want these things
here's what i use and i've tried to make
them as new player friendly as possible
not using xenophage if i'm going to go
farther xenophage is amazing
but i'm like basic machine guns doing
this stuff and i'm trying to make it
that way but it's like and then the
skill but as you said like
is it the whole get good moment maybe
that's the thing
yeah this is the thing it's it it it
feels like pve is having a moment that
pve pvp players accepted a long time ago
which is that if you want the thing you
need to put in the work
it cannot be a handout like yes okay it
is frustrating on the pve side of things
when
you need uh you need you need you need
to run a solar subclass
you need an arc uh secondary and then
avoid heavy and then
all of that is dependent on rng right
right and there's no deterministic way
to do it
but we are talking some about some of
the hardest content in the game even the
rates
require a certain loadout to do well
everyone's going to say do the lament uh
have xenophage
do this do that you could clear it with
a whisper
you could clear it with anything but
it's just easier and more optimal with
certain weapons
right and i think even at 1250s in the
state that they are
i think you could still do them with
anything you have it's just how much
risk are you willing to take and then
how
is that risk then attached to rng so i
do
agree with with with perhaps looking at
the rng but at the same time
i feel hard to recommend anything
because i play
this game more than the average player
does absolutely and therefore i'm
exposed to more drops and more sources
of loot and all that all the rest of it
but fundamentally i'm my take on this is
like if you want the thing put in the
work
which like if it's hard for you you are
not short on resources to
to find out how to make it not hard
enough or a little bit easier
i i guess go check out go check out
montes on youtube
okay yeah i'll make it easier for you
yeah
i i i i agree with you i mean overall i
think the premise is correct i don't
i don't think he's saying anything
incorrectly i i the only
i don't even call it a counter the only
thing i feel that leads to
tip to scale a little bit what i said is
rng protection but the other thing
honestly
is let's be real us the hardcore so to
speak
we have these optimal things we have
xenophage we have we have i've outbreak
perfected like i have optimal things
that
mr new light is not having you know what
i'm saying and mr new light it
he's not going to have the entire
loadout for you know
which you know um arc or void
scout and he you know i'm saying
overload this and then he may not have
the perfect thing to do it optimally
whereas we come in with a set advantage
because of their issues
with the pve loop pool that's why they
they've removed so much out right
they don't need to be optimal to do it
though that's the thing
as long as they don't need to be optimal
to do it then that's fine yeah
i was like to what he's saying i was
looking for
some people were saying hey scouts are
better for overload
and for somebody who's not trying to use
say non-hunger say they want to use a
void scout rifle instead if i need void
for shields
i was looking for a void scout rifle
there is a new one in season of the hunt
but even that like if you're going
through and you're trying to get that as
a drop that's not even a guarantee right
now
i got one i had one of those sitting in
my lure
and i was like oh damn i'm gonna go get
that right now and i switched and ended
up using that to beat the one i was
working on
but i had to go find that specific thing
it's random what that lure
has as options yeah so for certain
people if i'm like
hey this is in the game right now but i
can't guarantee how to go get it
that's a tough spot for some people and
that's like that's the time and the
grind and we've played enough to have
those options
but the loophole i will say is thin
right now and i know the discussion that
we had from
um joe groth that was like it was nice
for him to even admit
which we haven't even
maps gambit ever like the most things
are not usable right now
than they ever have been and that's
hopefully going to change for one by
what they said they're going to continue
to
make it bigger even season by season
they're claiming that
seasonally it's going to continue to
grow
which is a good thing but yeah there are
certain times when you need specific
things that they
they're going to tell me that barrier or
they're going to tell me overload is one
of two things
and if this shield and this barrier
don't match up too well with the loadout
right now you can be in a tough spot
so that's why i think right now the it's
it's hardest probably
right now because of what happened with
sunsetting sure
yeah i agree with that
he's in his bag right now now i forgot
to say so what are we going to
transition to the uh
yeah i wanted to see what you guys
thought about the uh the dev update yeah
sorry this is a long podcast by the way
we are uh yes we are in the
we got so far out of touch by talking
about like
lost sectors and everything else we
haven't got to half the time
of the day but it's been great it's all
it's all destiny you know
yeah yeah we were back on course after
uh talking about cars yeah we
we'll take the blame we started that for
just a little bit um
but joe blackburn uh he did actually
leave bungie for a little bit came back
he's assistant game director on destiny
2
put out one of these rare kind of
behind-the-scenes developer diary posts
that they did
and they kind of talked about the state
of rewards
they mentioned the reward loop pool was
just too small
to hear a developer flat out say that
not about a month
after the release that's kind of a
transparency you don't expect
yeah it's that's true so it they said
it's also frustrating this is our topic
frustrating to be a player a dis playing
destiny and see another player use a
weapon that is no longer obtainable
fell winter slime is a prime example
right now for pvp
because here's something that everybody
can use for
you know six months or however many
longer
but you can't get it right now period
but it's got the most kills in crucible
or one of the most now the other thing
is the side of what they promised or
committed to
and they said with each season in year
four destiny 2 will grow the overall
power ecosystem for weapons
so in theory if we lose the weapons from
season of dawn we're getting more in
season 13
is what i'm reading that is so hopefully
we continue to
fill our weapon options out more than
they are now we're not losing
we're not losing more than we're getting
it should be the other way around
they said with very few exceptions all
weapons you can take the power cap
should be earnable
except for like holiday weapons which is
fine they're usually not that great
and they said future annual releases
will contain more new weapons to collect
than beyond lighter shadow keep
and that's just a commitment to say the
loot pools and annual expansions
are going to be bigger so
just those two those kind of like
acknowledgements and commitments
when you guys got this far in it what
were you guys thinking
do it no matter what you think
it's it was reassuring
in a big way because they understood
that they made a mistake
it just it just it's a mixture of
reassuring and frustrating because we
shouldn't have been in this position to
begin with
i'm still not convinced sun setting was
was particularly good
mainly because we didn't get the
replacements like it felt like oh we're
sunsetting things
and then next season we see annoying
hunger come back and
stop talk about it night watch came
right on back
we had our ring small come back and then
even with the current loot
in iron banner these are reprised
weapons even the armors are prized
and it just feels disingenuous it feels
very strange
like if you want to call half the
weapons in the game
cull half the weapons in the game don't
don't do this thing about sun setting in
max power and
make it more complicated than it is it's
it it just feels it feels like somebody
had an idea
and somebody explained it to somebody
once and then there was a bit of a
chinese whispers thing going on in the
studio
and then something didn't get translated
fully and now we are in the situation
where we have no loot pool
so it's it you know like yes good that
they're fixing it bad that we're in this
situation to begin with
uh i agree all of this all of this the
the talk about new life players not not
being able to to feel relevant
it is yes it's important it's an
important thing to
to note but it's also probably not the
most important priority on
for the sake of the game how many new
players are bringing in we don't have
that data we actually don't know how
many new players are playing this game
right now
we don't know how many people who have
joined in season one season two season
three
season four sorry year one year two year
three year three or year four
um so we wanna have this discussion
about something that we don't know how
big
or relevant it actually is and
i don't know yet like don't get me wrong
this entire update was very positive
but i'm not sure if this is the
conversation we should be having period
aside from the looper loop issues are
very real but um
keep like correcting mistakes i think is
i don't know i i'm very mixed about it
no i mean
we've we had a whole you know sunsetting
discussion as well we've been through
that
and the way sun setting has been
implemented right now
is not great because the discussion of
sun setting is
hey we're going to make some stuff
that's old less relevant
as we're going to be bringing in new
stuff now we're going to change the
number make you
re-earn a weapon that's a very very
different discussion if you said
hey the stuff from year one and destiny
it's not useful anymore we're going to
get rid of some of that old stuff and
some of these old things but
we're going to introduce a whole new
slew of things bunch of new things to
drop and there's a bunch of new
options and it's new now the question of
resources how many resources do they
have to develop and they literally
mention the rewards team
is going to be growing in this article
to be like we don't have enough right
now and that's an issue as you said
this is an estate we should be in they
you know
like cross the road before they looked
and they like they got to the point
where
hey we're going to do this thing but we
don't have the team to make sure it's
implemented well
so we have to reissue iron banners and
non-hungers and night watches that have
the exact same perks
it just has a different icon in the
corner to piss you off
yeah and and completely spits in the
face of
you know the initial vision which was
remember oh we want this to be
your better devils and you're going to
have you know this insane relationship
with these guns and
you know oh that's so good and then
we're going to give you these
we're going to give you this pve or this
pvp kill counter
and that's going to show you how many
kills you got with this gun and you're
going to have this relationship
and it's going to be yours and now we're
going to sunset it all right cool which
admittedly i was resisted i've been you
know like okay
i get it i get power creep i'm not
saying the arguments are not valid
you know but yeah i was concerned you
know what i mean so i said all right
i'll bend the knee i'll acquiesce you
know long as you leave my exotics alone
and i'm like all right cool and then
like like all that clockwork like no man
said you get the new season
here come night watch here come you know
knowing hunger okay i'm like what like
you just told me like you you get rid of
all this stuff and then you got the
nerve the audacity to remix my joint
and give it right back to me with a with
a higher power double and then i lost
all my kill counter
i lost my master work all my material
back i see you ready
get it
when i when i was like thinking about to
myself why am i so bothered by this
it comes down to messaging versus
actions for me
the messaging from bungie the messaging
from bungie
is we want destiny to feel like an ever
living
world we want it to feel like it's a
hobby for you
we want you to spend time in this game
and we want to make you feel like your
time is rewarded
putting infusion caps on weapons and
armor i understand
completely making the game fresh i
completely get that
i think that's good for the state of the
game i think that's that's needed
what i don't particularly like
about that is that it
completely kills the incentive for me to
make destiny a hobby
because i know that whatever i get today
will
be outdated or or replaced or
completely invalidated tomorrow
i know that in a year's time my my
builds and went on
are are going to be completely useless
so
what this does is instead of perhaps
during the off season
the slow months in destiny which we're
sort of kind of coming into now
is instead of like chasing for those
roles chasing for that
perfect build chasing like a unique
ice full mantle build paired with tami's
matchbook which is a build basically if
you
proc icefall mantle you get that
overshield and then you just
spray and play with tommy's and it's
it's super fun it's not it's a complete
meme
meme me build but it works in sixes and
like i would want to prioritize a high
resilience
build for that to get my barricade up
i'd want to prioritize
um you know recovery so i get my health
back quicker
you know i want to i want to go and and
go the extra mile
to really rerun certain activities to
get the the loot and the
the armor and all that and maybe even
look for certain
sec primaries and and power to to
complement that build
but now i don't care because i know that
i'll just get one instead of min maxing
i'll
only be really wanting to get something
that
just allows me to do it good enough
because i know i'm going to be able to
spend my time
somewhere else and right now that's
probably f1 2020 or
or cyberpunk or something else you know
in the world i'm not getting the the
the the feedback that i want out of my
place i'm not getting
the extra mile out of my play time and i
understand this is a completely a
problem my own making
i play too much video games i'm gonna
own it so i'm also going to own
the discussion about my time and how
much that's worth to me
yeah no respect like you you can go
first because i'm going to open large
yeah i know you about to go in um yeah i
mean like i said the last thing
you know we said that you know again no
man's saying it he said it so eloquently
it's like
we get it we appreciate your
transparency
but we shouldn't have been in this
position to begin with
like that's just what it is like it's
just you you got to plan better we
sorry you got to do better bungee like
you cannot say
you make was it four blog posts we had
the luke smith joint
why sun setting is happening you know it
was a big divisive thing and then you
implement it in this kind of half-assed
fashion
you're going out you're going to get
this work you know what i'm saying and
that's just what it is so
you know and then on top of it you know
again love beyond i don't want to trash
the team like listen
we we we put thousands of hours in this
game we love this game this game is a
good game
right the issue just comes down to you
know
implementation and doing things
correctly to respect your base
respect your base so if you know you are
going to implement this sun setting
thing
you should have weapons in place and you
know what i knew something was up
when they um they i wanna say like a
stealth patch but
remember like i would say like one week
into the season
banshee automatically had like stuff
thrown into his loop pool
yeah i was like normally we'll get the
blog post
on the 12 and telling us what's about to
happen
and i'm like this is interesting and
again i wasn't mad i see some seven
serif weapons in there
i see some like okay i'm cool with it
but this was like a rush to get this in
and i realized yo that pool is small and
the last thing
that i'll say before i give it to you is
we talked about it is
to me it's just disrespectful when you
do like shadow keep content or whatever
and they're giving you unusable guns
yeah yeah
the game is rewarding you with the loot
pool
and there's an icon grayed out with the
power level grip this
is useless like bruh
we got a problem you know
so that that's you know where it's at
and the last thing i know you're going
to touch on the e
is that i might be pushing back now
i beg to need the weapons even though i
didn't necessarily like it
i may be pushing back on armor oh no
that's what i'm about to open on
oh okay i'll let you go because i don't
i don't know
fam why no i mean they said it in chat i
forget exactly who shout out to
the name also shout out to all the love
going on in chat right now
thank you very much you guys are being
awesome right now just missed y'all
we missed y'all man uh yeah
so oh technical thank you for the love
no it was crazy
i think it was crazy wise who said it
armor has been something for me for all
i've harped on this for too long cognito
knows i can't get off the horse and i
won't
reach it armor doesn't do much for me in
the first place
because it's just like kind of stats
that you can literally go into
any activity you can be optimized on
some things crucible probably more than
pve
as a pve player you could have some more
resilience you can get your cooldowns
back faster but theoretically
you can go through about any encounter
and your arm is not going to change too
much it's not
there's no and there's not much to earn
compound that with sun setting i have a
loadout of decently rolled armor
i have decent stats i finally got the
one i want what happens a year from now
what's the only thing that i'm trying to
do i'm trying to get the exact same
thing a year from now because what i had
that worked
that if i want the exact same thing
that's an issue and if you're making me
just do it again
to hit the slot machine to hope i get
that same thing
that's dumb just straight up that i mean
dumb is a
you know low key word but that's just
like that's the thought
that's not rewarding yeah so the issues
i have as i read this and i say
hey the nightfalls are actually getting
three new unique weapons
the palindrome the swarm and shadow
price from destiny 1 are going to be
your unique strike weapons i'm going
you can't make three new ones
i'm not mad that there's strike weapons
now because we've been asking for that
but now we're getting destiny one
weapons and like the adept version of
shadow price part of me just like part
of me is like
like and i know that may be the wrong
reaction because some people may be like
hey an adept shadow price may be very
cool
and maybe it is but in my mind that's
like
real really that's that's our strike
weapons this
is the swarm of grenade launcher
somebody correct me
a machine gun machine gun okay
uh shadow price and auto rifle
palindroma hand cannon
there's three potential adept weapons in
like grand master nightfalls and then
can i can i make it bold
yeah okay i got off my door and i'm
coming back matador is going to return
once fell into the sunset
what i'm making a bold prediction that
matador
64 is going to return because remember
in destiny 1 we had felt winter's
sniper because it was ridiculous and
then matador came out as
a response to that as an alternative to
that and
i fully expect that to be the plague of
year four moving forward once it gets
come back once it comes back we don't
know if it's gonna come back but
that's my prediction it'll come back and
again it'll be it'll be a destiny one
weapon it'll be a destiny one weapon of
some description
um the seasonal weapons aside from
friction fire i'm pretty underwhelmed by
them
talk about it it's just it feels like
season i mean activity armor
that is just the ice it first it's a tr
i'm talking about the the stuff
shacks the drifter and zavala
have as a seasonal armor where it's the
same armor with the color and it's
what's ugly let's just get it out the
way it's very ugly
it's atrocious right it does not even
look anything
comparable to what's in the eververse
store
and then you guys to just not even
change it for the other activities
you just threw a shady green red
whoever
is in charge of core playlists because
apparently we don't care enough about
core playlists to update them
um uh we'll throw in some destiny one
weapons i bet you'd
do the same for uh for pvp they'll like
reissue a stringer or bring back is luna
and actually call it ice luna
yeah it's just it was like you look at
some of these somebody mentioned earlier
in chat you're getting adored so you get
beloved with a scarf on it
yeah i mean people are like hey it's a
pretty good sniper i'm like did you like
your beloved though because it's next to
the same thing
yeah they just threw on the short gay
scope and then called it a day
so it's i was like and then armor is
like the one now they mentioned they're
like preheating the oven
we envision a better solution for how
armor intersects with infusion caps the
personality of armor comes from mods
right now
so gaining a new piece of armor often
means just trying to find a piece of
armor that replicates the stat
allocation you already
have on your piece in the vault i'm like
yeah
just killing me every time so it's like
what is the point and it's like
they think about talking about an rpg
but rpg if i was level
whatever we are you would allocate your
stats
i've played too many games recently
where you can go into a skill tree and
be like i don't really like my
skill tree let me wipe it out and do it
again because you have the choice to
customize and play what you want
what if you just had a set number of
stats now is this where they're like
and then armor was a way to complement
that like you'd have
a vanguard set of armor so if you go run
strikes you get some benefits in there
like set bonuses things like that but if
you just had stats
because right now all we do is try and
hit a slot machine to hope for the stats
but it just is like it's a frustrating
thing and then as you said sun setting
just makes it
exponentially worse right and the last
part i'll make to this
egregious problem is you know resource
cost
costs like it's a difference when you
you maximize you masterwork this armor
and you have that what is it the plus 10
and you get the extra stats and stuff
like that
but like that ain't cheap bro like you
know ascendant show they want them golf
balls they want them prisons to get from
seven to ten
is an investment so you know it's not
like they
running around giving out this stuff
easily either you know what i'm saying
so
that's a problem you know i'm saying
that is literally a problem yes they put
a little band-aid with the ghosts now
that you can specifically farm cars but
let's be real i've been checking them
drop rates their drop rates are not
great on upgrade modules masterwork
cores and i have that ghost on all the
time when i'm doing these
activities so i've been testing it um
yeah
it's again if you're gonna do this then
you have to give us
access to these resources that are fair
and a little bit plentiful so that i can
want to invest
right because you could tell me at once
to get to 13 10 or 14 10 or whatever it
is
i won't do this all over for the same
thing again so i'm i'm at that point
with all my like
why why are we even and last week and
i'll give it back to the one last point
someone said in the chat i think it's
back for that deep soul [ __ ] beautiful
rape
right raid on mods okay
why is the raymond costing well i talked
about
how much oh it's five five run a scanner
mod
run a thing four or five i've mentioned
this before
it came out too you did you did i really
it really bothers me i'm like you put
this in
and now i have to break my build now i
got to break charge with light builds i
got to break
you know i got to think and then they
got element ones
again with only goals i'm like oh wait
i saw the thing it dropped the mod for
me out the chest i'm like oh cool
so i guess i didn't have the appropriate
arc one on
and i'm like where is it and i had to
wait to get an
arc version of the same arms to put in
the mod
no bungee no it's bad bungy
they clearly built that system for more
mods to fit in and to compete with each
other but right now there is no
competition so
it feels like a bit of a joke um i
completely forgot what i was going to
say i was almost i'm sorry i interrupted
you i was just yeah
we were talking about armor i know i was
going off on a tangent with arma cost
yeah yeah there was a there was there
was an idea i had i don't know how
viable this would be but basically
have tier three tier one and tier two
armor where where it's sta
set stats and then allocate energy slots
to improving the stat distribution as
you see fit so it'd be an even split
every time i don't know if that would
solve anything or if it would make it
even more thin than it already is but
i'd yeah i just don't like the slop
machine aspect of it
the other thing i was going to say i
just remembered it was
if you're going to sunset my [ __ ] in a
year give me a new core playlist
or core gameplay experience to replace
that
that's the only thing i don't want to be
doing the same activities year on year
and year
okay i'm done with that we've done that
for seven years let's move on
yeah yeah no i mean crucible is talking
about
zero it was hawk and chat he said
where's his pvp
maps zero and you ripped out how many
did you lose yeah i was going to say
you're actually negative net
12 maps 12 maps yeah we've lost 12 maps
where's the one new europa map right can
we can pvp
you're stupid yeah
i'm so glad you're here because it's
like i get you you're my man i know
you you love you you love people stuff
like you don't you don't hate pvp but
it's just nice
we're so beaten down stepchildren of
this game like
we get scraps and we get so excited for
scraps and reusable things
like we didn't even get a map of the new
season location not one like
yeah how do you the minute and th and
the second we get a single piece of loot
that might be better in pvp than pve the
whole internet [ __ ] explodes
it's why let us have this let us have
foul winters lie
just just just [ __ ] off
they don't want us to have that man they
don't want to have none
oh please sir can i have a map yes can i
have my back
please sir can i have trials get
charleston oh don't even
open that get it can i get my
competitive tv
oh my god look the only thing saving me
from going off the deep end
just to make it fun put a ball in it is
shout out to um shopper boy fallout um
what you call it that your 120s bro
oh steady hand is that a 120 what what
120s bro what's that what's that dude
what's that i like to point out that i
made a video on 120s first
maybe yeah you did shout out to those
shout outs shout out shout out to you
first yes artistic integrity
bro you in your bag 120s is and that
that one that
is reprised it was an old gun that has
come back
with now the new pro yo that it's
hitting hard i was out there i was
putting it work
in better with that they're serious
they're what we wish
scout rifles could be yes that they're
literally
[Music]
so yes right now like they say hey
we want armor to matter prove it
because somebody said in chat i just got
my set this season i'm good till the
next expansion
so there literally is already half your
drops you don't give a [ __ ] about
this is apparently like the mature
podcast because we never guessed this
much but
it's coming out it's coming out yeah
it's like if i don't care about armor
for a year
and as you said like the raid mods
costing five and i just
lost my mind because yeah
the raid gear that you get should make
you better in the raid hey cool i got
this thing
here's the free set of mods that you can
throw on that you can compliment your
build
maybe i want to sherpa maybe i want to
do i've run the raid and i beat it what
is my incentive to run it over and over
and over and over maybe i want a sherpa
let me be better at it so i can help the
people who aren't quite as good
i've already beaten it i understand your
mechanics and i'm over leveled so it's
pretty cake anyway
let us be good at it and let us not take
away from what we already built
so yeah you had a yeah actually no the
only thing i was going to say in their
defense because i got to be fair you
know i know we're beating them up
um a lot yeah we are we kill them
you know in the defense they did
something i always wanted
which was the wrath of the machine
raid style rewards which they went away
from because bungie has this thing where
they introduce something
and then they go no we don't want to
bring it back because we want to evolve
it and make it more revolutionary
for no reason and reinvent the wheel for
no reason but
having the reward first of all the the
the weapons
unique unique perks shout out to
reconstruction that is a fire perk
you know what i'm saying i like that but
i do like the the fact if you keep
running it you can then at the end of
the chest say okay i want to farm for
this specifically
and it gives you incentive to to keep
doing it we just got to work on that
mod stuff with the armor stuff almost
still gotta get that you know whatever
whatever
couple other bullet points ddos four
consoles coming in season 13
cross play coming in 2021 yes
two strikes coming in season 13 we get
fallen saber in devil's lair
old refreshed legend and master lost
sector is going to the moon
thumbs up more of those are fun um
transmog season 14. i went back and
watched the video they said transmog's
coming next year
that was in june it's a year later
the shader system of consumables
has to go before then because i can't
stand the two of like i have eight of
these and 12 of these and seventy two of
these and two thousand four hundred and
eighty two of this bitcoin
it's not even it's not even an atom it's
not even an economy thing anymore it's
just annoying
yeah there's no like i unlocked it cool
let me use it there
they and the problem is you literally
see the second picture showing
the number that you have i'm like it
just should be an unlocked shader at
this point just scroll through the pages
i don't care
so but transmog potentially is coming in
season 14.
vault of glass raid returns in year four
they left that one pretty old
uh let's go let's go um
so i mean there's some some you know
some lights in here
in in the darkness of yeah what we're
pissed off about right now
i was like they're high volga is
probably going to return through a vex
based
season yeah i'm i was like timing wise
it's always the spring season that's
late that's still my where my money's at
for vault
so whatever's going to come in not the
february one
april may however long these seasons are
going to be i still don't know if
they're now in november release cycle
if they're going to try and change that
because i mean they bumped it back
are things going to get shorter or i
don't know i'm still wondering about
that
question unofficially become the
the the games month like last like
last november was crazy or this november
we just had was crazy
yeah well then so much is thankfully
delayed but i still haven't enough time
to touch
half the stuff i wanted to right right
do you guys have any major thoughts
about the donning
they're getting my money this [ __ ] looks
great
look in the gear low key low key i go a
lot
like all three sets are money they did a
great job and that's
always like the sets yeah the the
christmas lights ghosts i love that
and then the candle ghost which is now
forever
cursed in mime head because when we were
looking at the twab yesterday
in stream somebody said oh yeah that's
the [ __ ] ghost
[Music]
wow wow definitely going to mark this
one mature
we talked about it i don't think i do
we did everything we do what we did like
so we did it all day we we hit a whole
spectrum
of racy topics today yeah yeah
i don't think i'll be picking up the um
the adult ghost
um i will probably
be picking up all of their ornament
stuff i think
gameplay-wise will be the same boring
stuff that we've had for the last few
years
uh was not haunted forest but no it's
the baking
of goods stuff that we'll be doing right
oh yeah we do it basically go
run around get all your materials from
shooting this one type of enemy with a
melee or use swords to get all these
things
and bake your goodies they said the
exotic ship though you're going to be
able to upgrade
so enjoy the coast which is interesting
yeah in a new exotic ship complete with
a smorgasbord of features generate
dawning spirit to unlock your ship's
aesthetic delights
including three selectable engine
effects a unique transmat effect an
animated shader that's a part
that's as unique as the ship itself so i
don't know if
how those all unlock or if they're just
different things that we're going to be
able to get but
seems like that's going to be what we're
going for is the ship this time around
as opposed to a sparrow
which is fine i don't need metal and
spare going cha-ching
and just like farting out gold in the
back but yes the armor sets look fairly
fire
um also shout out to all of the game to
give which i think many of us have been
helping out with uh
they cracked a million dollars so far
for the bungie foundation and
the uh children's network of hospitals
so
down with all those that's still going
on through the weekend i know a link has
probably popped up in chat a couple
times if you guys haven't seen it
go find any of the people in destiny
they probably have a link out there to
donate
it's all going to the little lights it's
all to the kids so
if you are at a point right now we know
it's been a very tough year for a lot of
people but if you are able to donate
it's going to
amazing causes i mean the 400 every 400
is like an ipad in a kid's room
50 is a birthday party when we went to
guardian con they had a booth for saint
jude's
and they had the little vr goggles you
put on and you actually get to see
dude i was sitting there in the goggles
like it was done trying to like
blink away my tears in there because
dude that was rough
and i'm just like all the things that
they do so if you've got it they're a
million they're going for more
keep that going that's that's always
awesome to see
um last piece i didn't want to touch
touch on because i know this is one we
can't not talk about incognito next-gen
man
this is this is yours how how's it
feeling man
it's it's like it's like watching
you know your children graduate from
school
and it's like it's like yo like i i went
to college already and i like the out
listen
e i blame you man you showed me the
light
you made me pc bastard race for two
years ahead of scott's time and i'm
experiencing 60
players per second and when i
experienced it i promptly told my
console brethren
i'll see you later
i'm not doing that 30 frames a second
molasses
uh bad frame pacing situation that you
guys
think is good because even i was my
uneducated eye
at the time thought that was normal
right until i was
blessed with 60 frames right so then i'm
like yo
when y'all get y'all 60 i'll see you
guys again
finally the day has come you know and
look man it is
they did a fantastic job because not
only again you got that
you got the fov slider you know what i'm
saying you got
a couple other customizations and then
for me you know i
i do i have a lg or cx so i'm able to do
hdmi 2.1 with the 120 hertz
bro 120 hertz and the crucible just hits
so different
yeah it was so silky like
it felt like here's the thing that was
so funny because
i don't have these guys they got that tv
and they can't do that right
i don't i don't even i'm still 60 frames
on pc i'm not higher
the things i'm doing to people it's just
glorious
the it's the responsiveness the
precision i'm just like
i'm feeling like a god i never thought
console would ever
get there because i always felt they
were too concerned about complete
balance and unity between different
you know if you got an xbox one this and
then the playstation 4 versus
playstation
you know i thought they wouldn't do it
and they're finally adopting the pc way
of doing things
and it you know it's a and what's funny
is i'm getting apology letters from my
clan like
oh no [ __ ] we get it now now we
understand why you had to leave and go
to college
yes now you guys have graduated
understanding do not accept anything
less than 60 frames
that this is the standard now next-gen
consoles this is standard
it's glorious i'm doing a 4k hdr it is
absolutely spectacular
just the nvme e you know how it is when
you load into that
world and you're not sitting but there
was times i played destiny on console i
would literally do a bathroom break go
make a sandwich
and still have not loaded in
no like my brother uh his kids like they
got
tired of playing dusty on ps4 for one
because it's old ps4 but the load times
was just like
if you gotta like think about a quest
how many things you have to load between
and you're just like
i may as well read a book while i play
destiny because i have that much down
time it's
it's rough it's just good to see and
then now that we know we're gonna get
you know the cross plays on the rise you
know it's coming things are
getting up there and it's it's good to
see this unified thing we started with
cross save
you know now we're going to do this we
got the frames up we're getting there
man we're getting it's like i can't wait
cross play
is going to be the best thing for oh i
can't wait well i mean think about like
hey if i'm running if i want to help
somebody and
whisper the worm i was like i play on pc
so much and so many people like do you
play on console
no it won't matter i can just help
anybody in anything or whatever and
explain and it's like
that's gonna be a good thing nomad
sitting over there grinning ear to ear
i'm kind of curious why
well before we give it i got a shout out
here after he said it's funny because
you can tell who's on 30 frames per
second
like in pvp the anime yo you can just
like they even
they even shave them it's true because i
had to say that
people are almost gonna start being
shamed and to be like i need my ps5 why
because i can't play this old crap
anymore
i just want to say the two of you are
adorable
but more importantly just having seen
that reaction makes me happy because
it's vindication because i always i felt
like i was
it felt guilty playing on pc and
especially because my whole shtick is
about helping people and then
i said well i only do scrims on pc now i
only really play pc what people are
asking can you come back to console can
give you electric console
if i had one maybe but
god i get like when i we do this thing
on on my stream where i review gameplay
and i review people's gameplay they they
host they record a game they submit to
youtube and then
they post it in chat on my discord and
then i whip out the pen and i start
drawing all over their stuff when they
do things wrong
and when it comes to 30 fps
something that i'd forgotten is that
when you're
got when you're literally like this is
like this is your field of view on pc
and i'm console is like this oh yeah so
so like there's there's certain things
people do on castle we're like well why
didn't you like
just move out of the way and then i just
realized [ __ ] they can't because of the
fov
yeah and it's like you're literally
playing at half speed
you're reacting in half speed yeah
you're making plays in half speed you
can only do
half the amount of movements on pc it is
literally
or on 60 rather it's a different game
and now you're having this this
revelation of like
oh now i don't have time to make a cup
of coffee in between opening my menu and
trying to switch my weapon anymore
now i can actually play the game like
it's supposed to run like [ __ ]
facts yeah so anyways like i i'm happy
that
that that consoles finally are
they're not in the future they're in the
present yes
and they've caught up and now everyone
can experience destiny
in in this glorious manner people so
many people hit me up like
[ __ ] bro it's a different game i get it
now
i get it and i'm like yeah man now you
understand
why i had to leave you like and now
you know i can play with you you know
it's all good but yeah it's
it's just cool to see because i knew it
would it would blow people's mind and
it the reception that it's getting is
tremendous and
you know i say you know if you're on
xbox you got game pass you get beyond
light for free
you know what i'm saying shout out to my
playstation dudes they they in there
you know they rocking you know it's just
it's so good to see now the final step
let's cross you know bring this thing
together now we we may have to i want to
ask no man that
we may have to have that optional
check-in for pvp
because uh bouncing keyboard and running
ramp it might run ramping on them boys
i don't think so ah i don't think so
i've been smacked around by this thing
more times than i care to admit
oh no absolutely absolutely exactly so
it's like there's [ __ ] people who can
mop the floor with me like me
against drewski i know he's a controller
guys the first one popped in my head
would destroy me wouldn't matter what
input he's using so i'm like
i'll take my mouse and keyboard you'll
be fine people people
[ __ ] about controller users on pc a lot
and i think that is not the right
conversation to be having about them
i think we should be praising bungie for
creating an
environment on pc where controllers
not only compete with mouse and keyboard
but in some cases
outperform them especially with a lot of
these
weapons especially the aim assist heavy
weapons like
last word with a controller is a
different thing
forget last word
you know why because the stability on a
hawk moon is maxed out
and stability is the stat that governs
aim assist
variance the higher your stability the
less
variance in your aim assist between
shots so
hawkmoon's own assist is 93. it's one of
the highest
neutral aim assist guns in the game and
it continues that with shot to shot to
shot
whereas other guns it gets lower and
lower so you cannot spam
you can't spam the the fire button
quickly you have to time your shots
with hawkmoon you just d and you're
you're dead so that's that's why
hawkmoon works so well on controller
um so i'm really looking forward to
cross play
the thing one thing i'd say
competitively that might be an issue is
the 120
fps or even 240 fps i'm running um
there's definitely there is definitely
going to be some some some precision
advance overall precision advantage will
go to pc
but one thing that needs to happen is
that
consoles and pcs like next-gen consoles
and pcs
need to have the same sandbox tuning
they need
stability buff across the board so that
hand cannons on pcs
behave the same way as hand cannons on
consoles
yeah i wonder if that's an inherent
change that they try to do to try to
balance stuff like to try to to give the
controller guy
you know but i don't know it's an intro
i'm curious to see because
you know obviously it needs to happen we
want it to happen for you know but
some games do put that opt out i mean
you know that
opt-out option where you know console
guys only play pvp pve
should be no issue right you know we we
do race together we do strikes together
yeah that should be a non-issue my only
concern is if if pvp
they're willing and then we also gotta
remember don't laugh
stadiums advice don't laugh hey
apparently stadium is a good place to
play cyberpunk i hear
so yes that is involved you know we got
to see you know the
the streaming guys how that works you
know it
integrated into the the pvp thing so
i can't wait to go flawless on stadia
using elon musk's starlink internet
all the input lag give it to me now
uh has anybody touched prophecy yet i
actually haven't jumped back in
oh i need to but i haven't i know it
came out and i was like
too many things this week just too many
things but yeah prophecy is apparently
back everything else there were some
patch fixes things like that i'm not
gonna go through all that stuff but
prophecy came back so i'll be curious
how that plays but
yeah not too much new there either so
we've had you for a very long time
believe me
i appreciate the length of the podcast
but
um yeah i feel at some point we probably
should wrap this up for your sake
yes because we've talked for a while and
i don't want to keep you too long yeah
maybe
go on forever yeah we can talk for a
long time but
um this has been amazing thank you for
the crucible analyst and everything that
you brought to this podcast today
cognito i know is very excited to have
you oh dude i was like
getting a pvp guy i could talk freely i
don't have to say that bad word and did
hide
it's not like that in here my god you
know it
[Laughter]
making it over dramatic you know i got
those sauce on it
yeah yes i know believe me i know
so many episodes i'm fully aware exactly
thank you for having me oh dude it's
been a pleasure i was going to say at
this point i just want you to kind of
tell people
what you got to work on uh what you're
working on if there's anything you got
coming where they can find you
and then like one or two
general crucible tips that most people
don't think about just give them a
little uh
little nugget to end it on so they can
look forward to more from you
the big thing the okay so i am a
youtuber
primarily um i do stream and i have been
streaming this week
uh mostly just for games to give or game
to give
um and it's been going pretty well i'm
outstanding
out just blown away by the support of
the community even though i'm
i'm a pretty small streamer um
on youtube i will be releasing a video
either today or tomorrow
where i go and do a deep dive on
how we need to fix the crucible like
everything we've talked about
we go even further and i'll give you a
little i'll give you a little hint
exclusive 5v5
for casual and competitive
five playlists five different activities
individual ranks
okay i'm not going to say anything more
than that let's take it back to halo
watch the video this is the this is the
teaser for the trailer for the video
uh in terms of in terms of crucible tips
the biggest one is like somebody said in
chat so i'm curious
probably two second rule yeah
[Laughter]
the two second rule is this if no
targets appeal
appear in my field of view within two
seconds or less
i move away from the current position
and take up a new one basically if you
don't see anybody in two seconds
move that's it the other thing i'd say
is if you are not
comfortable with your guns do not be the
first gun in the fight mmm
smart i like it i get there
what man education out here it's great
pvp community man he needs this stuff
love the teaching
you know love the approach that you use
and um you know we just don't see a lot
of it and um
very analytical and thought-based and
it's just cool to see so as a person a
fellow person that loves pvp
you know we we need more so continue
fighting the good fight brotherhood
teaching the good word because uh
it is it is really cool to see i i
definitely got a chance to really
check like take a look a lot of your
content i was like wow this is really
well done so salute to eat for putting
me on you educate
thank you very much and thank you for
for doing that oh
no believe me it was a pleasure i know
we we almost didn't get to have this
discussion because work and other things
all changed up and then finally we
finally there was a shift and you're
like hey i'm open i'm like come on
we we are ready and it was perfect
timing too because
guys a lot of stuff going on perfect
time right before your video but just
crucibles in a place where it needs this
kind of discussion
and it does you are one of the better
people to talk about with it right now
because
the way you're looking at things and
trying to break everything down
for helping people get better not saying
as you said
don't use this weapon it's like doesn't
matter what
you're like you can use like using what
your hand is one thing
how you play the environment to another
and that's that's huge
more than anything i know you guys are
being very very generous and kind right
now because
i'm your guest and all that but i really
want to i really want to
emphasize how much damage the pvp
community has
has had has had because people don't
think for themselves
and the there hasn't been a mature
discussion
the reason why someone like me seems
unique is because
people have not thought for themselves
they have regurgitated
and chinese whispered people's opinions
to the point of
parody about everything and anything
regarding pvp
so please sure check out check out my
content
topic of course i'm going to say that
but more than anything
please know that just because
something's considered matter it doesn't
mean that's the only thing to use
please know please know that that
whatever i say
into today or tomorrow's video doesn't
mean that's the only thing that we need
to change for
for pvp and more importantly just go out
there and start
using weapons you like versus weapons
you think are supposed to be the ones
you use
because trust me you will you will enjoy
crucible so much more
if you're a scout rifleman go into
crucible right now and use a scout rifle
you'll be present pleasantly surprised
because we're we're we're in one of the
most balanced primary matters we've ever
had
i didn't even talk to you about the
metadata that's one of my questions and
real quick i gotta sneak it because um i
completely agree
um shout out to the iron man request and
you know obviously they force you most
people don't like it but you know they
force you to
to acquire a different weapon they give
you the weapon now and then you know
they let you go
and when it got to the scalp before i
was i had that cringe
internally i'm like all right and i said
you know what
let me do it i dusted off a couple of
scouts
i dusted off symmetry was it a 260. i
was getting killed with that
man symmetry is moving out here i was
like
okay so what's funny is again i'm guilty
of this i remember the change in the
twab
and they're like oh it's just an aim
assist buffalo didn't didn't do anything
what's goes
until i touched it until i played it and
experienced it
i'm like oh no scouts are very violent
viable
and um yeah i mean might is moving out
here a couple of couple of archetypes
that i was very impressed with so yeah
shout out to that and again
120s or something i i came across
different just experiment with different
things oh
that sidearm
the the the kinetic beyond like
yeah albert what is albedo whatever it's
called
bruh i'm putting in work with that thing
that thing is very good
yeah i got a well spring roll so i'm
getting my abilities i got my ark
buddies with me
i'm getting the synergy going it's oh
man i'm having them i'm gonna
even though crucible is what it is i'm
having a ball playing
messing around with it with this matter
it's it's a fun matter i will say
yeah it is my scrim loadout for for when
we do scrims next week we start that up
again my screen loadout is gonna be
chaperone and trusty
that's how much i love scout rifles now
and even high impact pulse is brought in
cold impact pulses
okay here's the thing people were
sleeping a cold denial last season as
well it's
objectively they're the fastest killers
in the game 0.67 seconds
like a truck um cold denial no time to
explain stars and shadows even
relentless the old trials of the nine
one
does does a lot of damage um if you are
feeling particularly masochistic you
could choose the istein d uh
which is a 340 with horrible base stats
yeah but it still kills it still doesn't
puts in the work so
use anything and it'll probably do the
job even even 180 hand cannons now feel
good
oh
bro prosperity is giving luna
a vibe i saw the video though man i'm
with everything you said i said you know
what let me give it a shot
i got what is and i were talking about
it right after we made our individual
videos on it
and it's like oh somebody would need to
dab things
out um we're looking we're
comparing pre-nerf not forgotten
to posterity stat for stat
they are virtually the same gun
so it actually is not forgotten give it
a shot that you know what it is e
super stable consistency and it's just
it's real it's really good easy to hit a
head shot it's it's not
bad man and i'm not a 180 guy oh it's
time
it's time nobody got one over the house
there we go
ladies and gentlemen we are back we took
two weeks off
you know during that time man it's the
holidays sometimes you got a little you
know extra fat around your stomach
it's time to be healthy gentlemen and we
got each showcasing proper form the
sit-ups and push-ups it is time
you got thanksgiving that you're just
working off right now you got christmas
coming up so we got to get the covered
belly down we got to get the holiday
belly down
and these are things we do here we have
the last word we promote fitness and
health
and well-being we want you to have the
last word on your health
that's what it's about this is what we
provide it's the service we provide
right for you
we're we're very pro-balanced
diets yes we like we like a balanced
meta as well
and we're open to experimentation of all
sorts whether it's new exercises or new
guns
yeah you know we will we're we're also a
diverse podcast here
um you know just just improve your life
stop thinking this stop thinking the
same way exactly look at that
he's like he listens to you they had two
weeks of miss man
they had to catch it they fish yo justin
said this is why something
this is what it's about man healthy body
healthy mind
healthy meta healthy tv it's all synergy
man
we come full circle thank you for your
service what
you know the worst part is every time i
do that i'm over there i know he's
saying stuff
i never know what he says i know you've
never heard it
never heard any of it listen man i've
got glowing reviews glowing reviews
right positivity brother what are we
doing that's what we do here
it's good to be back good to be back sir
yeah
well i know we got nomads outro what do
you got coming cognito
yeah man uh write it down end of the
year you know same thing so uh check us
out iron ore podcast on
sunday 11 a.m eastern running out on the
11 a.m this will be a big
two more before we go back to 1 p.m
eastern but um
no guess no big guess this week no
industry guess microsoft's not pulling
up this week
but um yeah we're just gonna be just
gonna ask the lords and uh we're gonna
do a nice little recap we're gonna talk
some cyberpunk
we will discuss um obviously that's the
60 frames per second
and um on console as well as the game
award recap you know that kind of stuff
and i believe halo infinite has some
news
dropping in reference to the development
team so check us out again online
podcast on youtube
sunday 11 a.m eastern on youtube on
twitch and then um
again um launch gaming.net man please
support the writers we've been doing a
tremendous job
really you know the support has been
tremendous the editorials we're seeing
is cool
so check that out and of course you know
what i'm saying
the last word returned finally in
glorious
it felt weird not doing it last week i
must have made it yeah no i know we were
supposed to
my internet's still been questionable
hopefully a week or two might
i swear i'm just going to have like a
brand new everything between me and the
internet so
hopefully at some point it works well
yeah shout out to black iron base and
miss shaw yeah
it does feel weird we missed but like i
said we're back at it you know he's
that's my brother it's always fun
hartwell was classic nomad was amazing
salute to you
you know i mean definitely got to bring
you back because i love i love your your
thought processing it takes hot takes
so juicy takes my thickness
they're thick
thick thick with two c's this distance
away from like
well when you're close to the microphone
it's theresa or even four seas
thick
and yeah that was the last word man
fun show chat was on fire man salute to
y'all man you guys have
all been amazing we definitely got to go
out there somewhere so let me see where
we're going
while i do that um thank you guys very
much this has been an awesome episode
sir nomad thank you very much for
joining us this morning glad we got to
make it happen and it has been an
absolute pleasure this morning to have
you so thank you first off for letting
us uh chat with you
it has been a pleasure to be here and
thank you for having me
and for me you guys know it's gonna be
cyberpunk demon souls destiny whatever
i've got going you guys know where to
find me twitch twitter youtube
i'm the easy one if you find ibontis and
a cheetah hopefully you guys
do enjoy the new sign out uh my offline
screen
uh the artist the artist that did that
one she absolutely nailed it so
that one's really really cool digging
that one um
just to throw the love back out i want
to send it over to zoey when we're done
actually so she's out there working so
she's always really nice and awesome we
had her on previously so
we will send the love over to zoe but
before we go we got in this thing right
um so when we're all done we're gonna
try and sync up saying the last word
together so nomad we'll see how this
goes
uh but for everybody in the chat thank
you guys very much send some love over
to zoe she's always awesome and nice
and as for this episode it has been
the last word